Nimmst du gerade auf? Ich nehme jetzt auf, ja. Ja, soll ich mal eine Ankündigung machen mit meinem geilen Resonator? Wer fällt mir dazu nicht ein?
Kannst du mal bitte Tim das Effektgerät wegnehmen?
Das klingt doch total crazy, oder? Da hat jemand ein tolles Spielzeug zu Weihnachten gekauft.
Hast du eben schon deinen Sohn erschreckt?
Nein, nein, nein, das ist auch ehrlich gesagt, ich hab das jetzt heute das erste Mal alles wieder mal so richtig zusammengezuppelt. Ich hab ja ein ähnliches Setup schon früher gehabt, bloß ich hatte immer keine Geräte, die eine Latenz liefert, mit der man das auch machen konnte, sodass man das im Kopfhörer hört. Ich bin total beeindruckt, ich hab jetzt hier in meinem Setup den normalen Analogmixer durch so ein digitales Audiointerface mit Mixer-Funktionalität, die ich jetzt eigentlich gerade gar nicht nutze, ersetzt. Das heißt, jeder Mikrofonkanal kommt separat in meinen Computer rein, rauscht einmal durch den Ableton Live durch. Und da hab ich mir sozusagen auf meinem Mac meinen Mixer zusammengeklickert und kann halt jederzeit mit Dreck und Drop irgendwelche komischen Effekte und Dings rein machen. Wie sieht das aus? So sieht das aus. Schick, oder? Guck mal, wenn ich jetzt hier auf Resonator klicke, dann bin ich sofort viel cooler als sonst. Jetzt wo du es sagst, richte ich es auch. Na, wenn du auch cooler sein willst, Max, dann kann ich dich ja hier auf so ein anderes Präzip werfen. Wieso? Hier so Rom klingt auch sehr cool. Rom? Na, was kann ich dafür, dass der Effekt so heißt? Rülps nicht ins Rom. Naja, ich glaube, wir lassen das erst mal sein, aber...
Kann mal wer den Livestream-Link im Irk posten, bitte?
Den Livestream-Link im Irk posten? Aber ich hab doch den gerade getwitthart.
Ist mir egal.
Schon gemacht. Wie auch immer. Hallo, willkommen zu Mobile Macs Nummer 19, die letzte Ausgabe unter Garantie im Jahre 2008. Und ich sag nur Ho Ho Ho, wir haben uns hier weihnachtlich gemütlich zusammengesellt zu Spekulatius und...
Wieso?
Die nächste Sendung ist am 31. Das ist ja wohl klar.
Das sind zwei Wochen.
Darüber reden wir noch mal?
Darüber reden wir noch mal. Ich glaube, das wird nix. Aber who knows? Und was gibt's hier noch Schönes? Es gibt hier so Lebkuchen.
Genau, Dennis hat irgendwelchen Luxus-Lebkuchen aus.
Ist auch ein Kühlladen, aber.
Was ich mich wirklich frage ist, handelt es sich bei Lebkuchen eigentlich um ein Imperativ?
Das erlässt schon ein bisschen länger.
Entschuldigung, der Bitz war nun wirklich etwas gestresst. Wie auch immer. Wir haben tolle Themen auf unserer Liste. Und wir haben ja auch ein paar Themen gesammelt auf unserer tollen Webseite, während wir Spekulatius-Mampfen und Glühwein schlürfen. Und, ja, da ist natürlich, fangen wir damit gleich an, mit dem Thema.
Mit dem hottesten Thema überhaupt.
Mit der heißen News, mit der großen Depression.
Du meinst die neue BB-Edit-Version?
Das ist die große Depression.
Ich hab mir eine neue Tasche dabei. Was? BB-Edit? Ich hab's mal gekauft, aber die Penner haben die Version, die ich mal gekauft habe, nicht mehr so zum Download. Das heißt, ich bin nicht in der Lage, meine Lizenz auch wirklich zum Einsatz zu bringen. Hätte natürlich da jetzt ein bisschen Stress machen können, aber ehrlich gesagt hat mich BB-Edit immer ein bisschen genervt.
Also BB-Edit war doch so irgendwie cool so in den 90ern, oder?
Ich bin so ein Kind der 90er, darum habe ich bis heute zum Beispiel diese Liste jetzt gerade in BB-Edit getippt.
Aber du steigst ja nicht auf Text-Mate um?
Weil Text-Mate hat einen Haufen Features nicht, die BB-Edit hat.
Das stimmt. BB-Edit ist schon ein ganz schön fettes Teil. Aber es ist halt auch so ein bisschen, es versprüht auch noch so diesen Geruch von dem Text.
Na ja, den werden sie langsam los.
Sie werden den langsam los.
Ziemlich sicher. Das ist wirklich viel, viel besser geworden. Klar. Und vor allen Dingen so eine 100 Megabyte-Datei, probiere dir mal einen Text-Mate aufzumachen. Das ist echt ein Problem.
Ja, es performt super mit großen Dateien, vor allem mit vielen Dateien. Aber es gibt einfach so zwei, drei Sachen, ich weiß nicht ob BB-Edit da aufgeschlossen hat, also diese Project-Folder-Opening-Geschichte, zum Beispiel, in Text-Mate finde ich ja ganz geil.
Es gibt sowas Ähnliches?
Dass du einfach einen Ordner aufmachst, und dann hast du automatisch so einen Sidebar.
Das heißt der Disk-View, aber das ist nicht ganz so gut wie in Text-Mate.
Ich habe wieder voll das Thema gesprengt. Du wieder!
Die Autocompletion, die heißt nicht Completition, die heißt Completion, wie ich in der Zeit meinte. Die ist wesentlich schöner in BB-Edit mittlerweile als in Text-Mate. Und zwar, dass er tatsächlich auch Sachen vorschlägt, die man selber in seinem Wörterbuch eingetragen hat. Sowas zum Beispiel. Ist schon, ich mag BB-Edit nach wie vor. Ich setze beide parallel ein, aber BB-Edit ist schon noch der Liebling.
Okay.
Aber sagt das nicht Text-Mate.
Ich warte, bis die große, große neue Release kommt, weil bei Text-Mate tut sich ja jetzt schon seit längerer Zeit nichts mehr. Aber sie haben ja angekündigt, dass die nächste Version, welche da sein wird, die, weiß nicht, was jetzt aktuell ist, die 2, was haben wir jetzt? Jetzt haben wir Version Nummer 158, genau, die 2.0, soll ja dann nur unter Leopard laufen.
Ja, das haben sie aber das erste Mal angekündigt, bevor Leopard überhaupt rauskam.
Ja, naja, aber da wussten sie schon, was Leopard sozusagen alles verspricht.
Ja, aber ich habe aufgrund dessen geschlossen, dass sie sich im Zeitplan minimal vertan haben. Also Text-Mate 2 könnte das neue Duke Nukem Forever sein.
Na ja, das wird sich zeigen. Ich meine, es ist ja derzeit im Macintosh-Markt so. Wer hat da so einen klugen Kommentar zu abgegeben? Das war hier der Will Schipley von The Delicious Library Macht. Ein Programm, was ja auch schon seit längerer Zeit kein kostenpflichtiges Update mehr gehabt hat. Die 2.0er? Nicht für die Leute kostenpflichtig, die schon eine Lizenz hatten. Das war sozusagen ein kostengünstiges Update. Also ein kostenfreies Update. Und er meint, derzeit sei es einfach so im Macintosh-Markt, es kommen so viele neue User dazu, dass seine Verkaufszahlen einfach konstant bleiben. Obwohl das Programm an sich schon alt ist, gibt es immer noch so viele neue Macintosh-Kunden durch diese unglaubliche Zunahme an Markt, die da seit 2 Jahren stattfindet, dass sich das nicht groß auswirkt. Deswegen könnte er sich das leisten.
Im Worten, der Marktanteil sorgt dafür, dass die Programme langsam verreiten.
Dass die Programmierer faul werden.
Ich meine, den Programmierern geht es dabei nicht schlecht, weil irgendwann wird dann natürlich auch mal eine Version 3 nachlegen und die wird dann was kosten. Und wenn dann alle User oder zumindest ein Großteil derjenigen, die sich angesammelt hat, dann auch wirklich upgraden, dann ist es sicherlich nicht zu seinem Nachteil. Also das muss jeder Entwickler letztlich selber wissen. Und ob das nun wirklich für jeden so läuft wie für ihn, weiß ich auch nicht. Aber es ist zumindest nicht so, dass es sich hier gerade um einen sterbenden Markt handelt. Kann man nicht behaupten. Gibt es wenig Indizien für.
Außer sterbender Markt, womit wir jetzt beim eigentlich depressiven Thema... War das eine Überleitung?
Nö, noch nicht.
Doch, doch, doch.
Wer als erstes auf das Thema eingeht, kriegt keinen Lebkuchen mehr, oder was? Ich hatte noch gar keinen, er damit. Heute muss es ja ein bisschen weihnachtlicher zugehen hier. Nicht, da raschelt es auch. Wir hätten auch wichteln können.
Ich hab...
Wir könnten Themenwichteln machen.
Ich musste letzte Woche schon dreimal wichteln.
Jeder schenkt jemand anderem ein Thema. Eins, was man vielleicht selber sonst nicht genommen hätte, aber wo man weiß, dass der andere es mag. Das wär doch was Schönes, oder? Ja, ach komm, also rein ins Thema. Welches? Na, das Thema, was gerade alle Herzen berührt, ist natürlich...
Weihnachten fällt aus.
Steve Jobs ist krank.
Steve Jobs... Ja, was ist passiert? Also, Apple hat angekündigt, dass A, Steve Jobs nicht mehr die Keynote machen wird auf der kommenden Macworld im Anfang Januar, sondern Phil Schiller, was ich ja so schlimm nicht finde, weil Phil Schiller ist...
Der hat mal nix drauf.
Ich mag Phil Schiller, das stimmt nicht.
Nee, der andere ist cooler, dieser... Nee, der ist auch schlimm.
Ich find die hier ganz cool. Der guckt immer so ein bisschen verrückt.
Der übertreibt ein bisschen mit seiner Magic Show. Nee, der Finanztyp, der Tim Cook, der war eigentlich ganz cool.
Ja, aber der ist finanztyp. Ja, aber es geht um Produkte. Der Chef von Produkte ist halt Olle Stief und der eigentliche Chef, der Vice President, der sozusagen der Produktsparte übersteht, ist halt Phil Schiller. Und Phil Schiller ist ja auch... Ich weiß nicht, ich finde den okay. Ich finde nicht, dass der Karis maffrei ist. Und ehrlich gesagt sind die Keynotes von Steve nicht sehr viel besser geworden. Also seitdem, er hatte nochmal so seinen Hoch mit dem iPhone, aber danach ging es echt bergab. Von Steve. Das ist eine richtige Fanboy-Sendung heute, ne?
Ich glaube, wir müssen uns damit abfinden, dass Keynotes in Zukunft so nicht mehr geben.
Da bin ich mir ja nicht so sicher. Ich habe schon eine Theorie. Ich auch. Ich habe schon eine Theorie. Es ist auf jeden Fall erst mal ein großes Geschrei. Oh Gott, wenn es keine Keynote mehr gibt, wie sollen wir ohne die Ansprache unseres Oberpriesters überhaupt leben und so? Selbstmordrate im Macintosh-Land steigt erheblich. Genau. Und diese Spannung und so. Bloß das Ding ist, dadurch, dass jeder weiß, dass da was kommt oder kommen muss, dieser Druck auch auf Apple lastet, immer nach Weihnachten was vorzustellen. Und dann kriegen sie es aber irgendwie nicht hin und dann annunzen sie irgendwas und es ist erst drei Wochen später verfügbar oder was auch immer oder ein halbes Jahr. Das nimmt ja auch eine ganze Menge von dem Fun wieder weg, finde ich. Aber wenn man noch nicht mal weiß, dass irgendwas total Kolossales, Großartiges bevorsteht, dass jeder beliebige Termin, der irgendwie angekündigt wird, mit oh, wir stellen jetzt mal was vor, das bringen kann, dann ist eigentlich der Spannungseffekt ja viel größer. Oh, es gibt ein Gerücht, dass nächste Woche ein Special Event ist.
Ho Ho Ho, haben sie da auch schon mal gesagt dieses Jahr, irgendwann, dass sie diese festen Termine nicht so richtig mögen, oder? War da nicht noch was? Haben sie das Juli-Ding auch schon aufgehoben oder sowas?
Ja, sie haben sich von der Macworld, also die andere Macworld, die ja immer im Juli so stattfindet, und zwar erst in Boston, dann ist sie nach New York gegangen.
Dann sollte sie eventuell wieder nach Boston gehen.
Genau, und zu dem Zeitpunkt, als sie das angekündigt haben, also erst fand Apple das nicht so gut, dass sie nach New York geht, und dann haben sie gesagt, ach, jetzt gehen wir doch wieder nach Boston, aber dann hat Apple irgendwie schon gesagt, nehmen wir jetzt nicht mehr teil. Und jetzt nehmen sie halt auch nicht mehr teil, und Adobe nimmt auch nicht mehr teil, und Belkin nimmt nicht mehr teil, und das Ding ist aber auch, weltweit gehen die Investitionen der Firmen in Trade Shows zurück.
Na wahrscheinlich, weil schon auch immer mehr eine Menge...
Das sind die größten Verlierer, denke ich mal....
online stattfindet, oder?
Finanzkrise. Ja, also erstens ist es halt sehr teuer, zweitens ist das Internet eigentlich schon immer das bessere Regal gewesen. Im Falle von Apple ist aber natürlich die Hands-on-Experience sehr wichtig, nur mittlerweile haben sie halt... 250 Stores weltweit. In Amerika sind sie... Glaub ich, gibt's einen Apple Store... Weiß ich jetzt nicht mehr die Zahl. Es gibt da irgendeine Kilometerzahl, ja, die jemand reisen muss irgendwie in Relation zu der Populationsdichte, tralala. Auf jeden Fall gibt's jetzt die Möglichkeit, wenn sie die Kino und Live übertragen in die Apple Store, das machen sie doch eh schon, oder? Also mindestens manche haben sie übertragen, wenn sie nicht sogar alle übertragen haben.
Kann sein, ja.
Das wäre doch eigentlich viel cooler, weißt du? Dann setzt er sich da irgendwie in seine...
Weil dann ist der Kunde auch gleich da, wo er es kaufen kann.
Er ist ein Star, sie können es gleich alle mit raustragen, aber ist halt auch eine viel größere Audience, weil wie viele Leute passen denn da rein in so einem Saal? 1.000 vielleicht oder 2.000, wenn es hochkommt. Na ja, können sie ja auch mal einen Stadion mieten, aber was kostet das? Und so machen sie einfach Live-Übertragungen in alle ihre Apple Stores, dann kommen die, dann kommen sozusagen alle gleich in die Kirche, gelatscht. Und es gibt halt nicht nur eine, sondern ganz viele. Und ist natürlich auch ein ganz anderes Happening, weil dann würde das auf einmal auch in Deutschland stattfinden, zum Beispiel jetzt, wo es in München einen Apple Store gibt. Habt ihr diese Bilder gesehen? Die Videos? Ich hatte nur Apple Store München.
Dieses 360-Grad-Bild?
Ja, aber auch die Videos, was da irgendwie abging. Ich hab mich ein bisschen geschämt.
Für was?
So fremd schämt?
Als Apple-User?
Nee, als Apple-User nicht so sehr. Mehr so als in Deutschland Wohnender.
Wieso?
Na, hast du gesehen, wie die sich da so, wie so ein schlechter Aldi da so aufgeputscht haben vorher? So dieses ganze Geklatsche und dieses Ja. Ich kam mir vor wie bei so einer M-Way-Verkaufsveranstaltung.
Aber kannst du dich noch an den Start des iPhones in Amerika erinnern?
Ja, in Amerika können die das doch meinetwegen machen. Das ist mir doch egal. Das, das, das, das buche ich unter USA ab.
Aber wir Deutschen haben so ein bisschen Grießgräbig zu sein.
Ich finde, man könnte sich ein bisschen benehmen.
Ein bisschen mehr Schlange stehen.
Ein bisschen mehr, ähm, ich weiß nicht. Ich fand's gut, ich war nicht da. Vielleicht war es gar nicht so schlimm. Vielleicht wirkt es einfach nur durch diese Videos so ein bisschen überdings so. Aber auch dieses Rausrennen und Give Me Five und so, das ist einfach, verstehst du? Man kann amerikanisiert sein. Man kann das auch toll finden. Aber man muss es ja deswegen auch nicht gleich machen. Ich finde, das passt nicht so zur deutschen Seele. Das ist einfach...
Aber zu denen, die da waren, hat es vielleicht gepasst?
Ich erwarte einfach ein etwas technokratischeres Grundverhalten.
Sie hätten mehr so Nummern verteilen sollen.
Ich hätte auch kein Problem damit gehabt, wenn die einfach eine Tür aufgemacht hätten. Dann wären alle reingegangen und hätten gesagt, das ist aber hübsch bei euch.
Ich habe Videos gesehen auf Quick von Leuten, die schon in der Nacht vorher berichtet haben, live davon und die da wirklich schon um 3 Uhr morgens rumgecampt haben. Da kam ich betrunken von irgendeiner Party wieder.
Ja, aber warum? Ich meine, warst du schon mal in einem Apple Store? Ihr wart beide noch nicht in einem Apple Store?
Na wohnen.
Gibt es in Berlin schon einen?
Verlasst ihr nie das Land?
Nee, die Stadt nicht. Ich komme selten aus meinem Bezirk.
Ich war jetzt schon in 2 oder 3 verschiedenen.
Oder? 2?
Meinst du, dass eigentlich mit jedem weiteren Apple Store Apple so ein bisschen uncooler wird? Das glaube ich nicht.
Aber das Ding ist, ein Apple Store ist wie der andere. Also die sind zwar ein bisschen anders, so.
Verschiedener Aldi.
Also ich war, wo war ich denn? Ich war in dem Apple Store in der Region Street in London. Das ist ja einer der größten auch. Kolossal.
Wieso einer der größte? War der größte?
Ja, aber mittlerweile ist es glaube ich nicht mehr der größte. Ich glaube der größte ist jetzt in Boston. Und dann war ich in Japan in dem Apple Store, also in Tokio. Der war ein bisschen anders. Aber im Prinzip ist es halt alles gleich. Und wenn du dazu auch noch die ganze Produktpalette von Apple auswendig kennst, und das ist ja eigentlich bei den Leuten, die da hinkommen, dann gibt es da einfach keine Überraschungen. Das ist so nichts anderes als, oder du warst doch bestimmt schon mal in dieser Apple-Ecke im Media Markt. Da steht dann so ein langer Holztisch, und alles ist schön irgendwie aufgedenkt und so weiter. Und dann nimmst du einfach dein Stempel-Tool und machst das Ganze mal 20, dann hast du einen Apple Store. Na okay. Gibt natürlich so ein paar Aspekte. Was ich an einem Apple Store toll fand. Dieser Genius Bar ist einfach wohlorganisiert. Gravis hat sich da ja auch was abgeguckt, hatte ich ja letztes Mal schon gelobt, so mit irgendwie Terminfeuer machen und so. Das ist alles ganz okay. Und was auch einem total umhaut, ich war da noch in Kanada, genau, in Toronto war ich auch noch in dem Apple Store. Und was einem total umhaut, ist die Anzahl der Leute, die da arbeiten. Also du kommst da rein und PAP hast du irgendwie schon so an einer an deiner Seite, der dich irgendwas fragt. Das ist ja horrible. Ob bei dir helfen kann. Ja aber nett, die sind echt gut trainiert. Du hast aber auch nicht so dieses Problem, wie in vielen Läden, dass du reingehst und dann suchst du so eine halbe Stunde und dann hast du irgendeinen Typen, der immer so einen Rudel von Leuten um sich herum hat. Ich habe so den Eindruck, dass die Apple Store-Mitarbeiter, die sind geradezu militärisch ausgebildet. Also weil die haben immer, die sind ja auch so in unterschiedlichen Gruppen mit unterschiedlichen T-Shirt-Farben. So, dann gibt es so diese reinen Empfangsleute und dann gibt es die Produkt-Spezialisten. Die Produkt-Spezialisten, die scharen sich halt immer so um diese Tische, wo es dann eben um iPod, Macintosh und so weiter geht. Und dann hast du halt noch so diese Empfangsleute, die sind immer schon ganz am Anfang. Das heißt, du kommst ran, dann kommt gleich irgendwie einer an und zieht dich irgendwie hin und verteilt dich. Und was ich auch sehr cool finde ist, die können dir ja auch wirklich, ohne dass du an die Kasse gehst, was verkaufen, weil die einfach solche mobilen Kassenterminals haben. Also das ist...
Aber du kriegst unter Umständen gar nicht mit, dass du gerade einen Kaufprozess gemacht hast.
Das kann natürlich auch sein. Naja, also wie auch immer, Apple Store an sich, tolle Innovation, so Laden. Hast du aber schon mal ein paar gesehen, dann ist es jetzt nicht mehr so aufregend. Aber vielleicht kannten die in München das alle.
Ich fand die Fahne ganz cool. Die hatten doch dieses aus iPods, aus blauen iPods.
Ach, dieses blau-weiß.
Da haben die diese... Tim, jetzt bin ich aber enttäuscht.
Weiß-blau.
Ist das ein Unterschied?
Ja, für Bayern ist das ein extremer Unterschied.
Wirklich? Warum?
Jetzt wirst du gelöhnt. Ich hab keine Ahnung, ob das irgendwie weiß aussteigt. Das schneiden wir nachher raus. Nicht schon wieder.
Dann war das Foto vielleicht falsch angeschnitten, was ich da hatte.
Beim letzten Mal musste man schon den Start-Termin von 10.07 rausschneiden.
Im Chat wird gerade kommentiert, dass die Leute ja da hinten so Trainings-Camps ausgestattet werden. Das stimmt, diese Applestore-Mitarbeiter, die werden ja alle noch mal nach Cupertino geflogen. Alle? Ja. Wirklich? Ich weiß nicht, ob ich das wirklich...
Cupertino-Bang.
Jeder Einzelne, aber ich denke, der Großteil im Wesentlichen schon. Die gehen dann wahrscheinlich einfach durch so eine Kammer, durch das Reality-Distortion-Field von Steve Jobs. Das haben die wahrscheinlich im Eimer so abgenommen.
Deswegen kann er auch keine Kino machen.
Durch so große Magnetkerne wird dieses Reality-Distortion-Field so in der Mitte des Campus vorgehalten. Das ist so ein leicht gründig leuchtender Nebelwand. Und da muss man dann so durchgehen und dann kommt man raus und dann ist man Applestore-Mitarbeiter.
Und Steve muss das natürlich vorher noch einmal absegnen. Der lässt nicht alle durch.
Was die Mitarbeiter?
Ja klar.
Meinst du, die werden auch noch einzeln so mit Weihrauch besprengt?
Bestimmt.
Und müssen ihre Sünden beichten?
Ob sie schon mal PC benutzt haben und so.
Das kann natürlich sein. Das kann sein. Naja, auf jeden Fall ist dieser Applestore jetzt da. Ich werde auch die Tage da mal hinfahren, plane ich.
Ach, nach München?
Ja.
Zum Applestore, nur zum Applestore oder einfach bei dir?
Nee, ich hab da auch noch ein Podcast-Projekt.
Du hast noch Verwandtschaft, die du nerven kannst.
Nee, ich hab keine Verwandtschaft in München. Also zumindest keine, die ich kenne. Aber ich bin eh so im Süden die Tage und dann werde ich auch noch mal den Weg dahin gehen und dann werde ich dann noch mal live, na nicht live berichten, aber ich werde dann noch mal von meinen live Eindrücken berichten, später.
Und dann können wir die parallel schneiden, deine Aussage eben gerade über den Appel Store und deine Aussage dann über den Appel Store.
Genau, wenn ich erstmal durch die grüne Nebelwand durchgegangen bin, ist das natürlich anders.
Oh mein Gott!
Ja, ich nehme alles zurück.
Das haben die vorher in der U-Bahn verteilt.
Wie auch immer. Ich finde nur, die hätten nicht so blöd schreien müssen. Mir hat das einfach missfallen. Ich finde einfach so, man hätte da mehr deutsche Zurückhaltung an Tag legen können.
Ach, ich finde das super.
Echt, aber warum? Ich meine, es ist ein Laden. Es ist ein Computer-Laden.
Aber da sind Leute, die haben die ganze Nacht davor gecampt. Die haben stundenlang davor gestanden.
Das ist mal ehrlich, Leute. Die verkaufen Computer.
Na eben.
Ja und? Ich meine, warum sollte, ich meine...
Tim, ist das da ein Dell-Laptop, der vor dir steht?
Komm mir nicht so.
Gut, also deine Theorie ist auch, dass Apple das halt einstellt, weil sie halt mehr ihre Produkt-Announcment nach eigenem Termin machen wollen und sich nicht so auf diesen Januar festlegen möchten.
Ich denke, es kommen mehrere Sachen zusammen. Das eine ist wirklich auch Finanzkrise. Das kostet halt einfach, ich denke, das hat ihnen zumindest die Entscheidung ein bisschen leichter gemacht.
So teuer wird jetzt so eine World-Dingster-Mac-World auch nicht sein.
Aber hallo, ist das teuer? Na, ich meine, die haben da ein Shitload von Mitarbeitern, die das vorbereiten müssen.
Na was kostet das? 1,5 Millionen?
Ich glaube, mehr. Ich glaube, dass es auch mehr kostet. Du hast halt, in der Regel läuft sowas eine Woche, oder?
Weißt du, es kostet sich Jobs einzufliegen.
Nein, mal ernsthaft. Du hast ja, wenn du schon mal einen Messe-Einsatz gefahren hast, warst du schon mal auf einer Messe für eine Firma? Dann kannst du so ein Etwa einschätzen so, dass das ist ein Riesenaufwand. Unterbringung, Transport, vor allem du hast unheimlich viele Leute, die eine Woche lang eigentlich nichts anderes machen, als auf dieser Messe rumzustehen und eben nicht arbeiten können an dem einzigen Kram.
Aber es ist ja schon halt auch ein dicker Werbedings, also.
Sicherlich.
Aber nicht mehr so stark wie früher vielleicht.
Ja gut, aber hätten sie den nicht, ich meine die Leute mal ehrlich, die zu Macworld kommen, die kennen halt die Produkte auch. Das einzige, was halt dann interessant ist, ist halt was Neues. So. Ja gut, aber das steht da eh rum. Auch auf der CeBIT standen die neuesten Macs überall rum und das, obwohl Apple schon seit was weiß ich wie viele Jahren da nicht mehr ist, seit 10 Jahren oder so und auch bei anderen Mac-Messen. Ich meine, am Ende geht es da einfach um den Macintosh-Markt, um die Händler. So und Apple muss sich da nicht wirklich zeigen.
Also ich kann das schon verstehen und dass irgendwie die Kosten sparen wollen und so weiter und dass das alles irgendwie anders geregelt wird und dass am Ende für die vielleicht ein Plus dabei rausfällt, aber so für mich als User ist schon so ein bisschen schade, dass da irgendwie so dieses Apple-Weihnachten einmal im Jahr so ein bisschen weg ist.
Also für mich als User ist es nur so halb schade, weil ich fand das bisher, also ich fand es damals, als sie noch live übertragen worden sind, die Keynotes, das fand ich geil. Da hat man sich da vorgesetzt mit Popcorn und hat vorher ein bisschen rumspekuliert, aber seitdem das nicht mehr live übertragen wurde, hat es doch sehr an Scham verloren.
Aber da kam es auch trotzdem zwei, drei Stunden später als Video, es ging noch auch noch.
Ja, aber das können sie auch in Zukunft machen.
Also klar, jetzt kann man sich aber schon so freuen auf so, im Januar gibt es wieder irgendwie Updates und jetzt ist so, naja, irgendwann vielleicht mal gucken. Also ich finde es schon ein bisschen schade, ich finde es schon gar nicht so schlecht.
Du glaubst doch nicht im Ernst, dass Steve Jobs das nicht weiß, welche Wirkung diese Kinos haben und ich sage dir, die haben was, die haben einen Plan.
Ich hoffe.
Die planen einfach was, was noch cooler ist, aber mit ihrer eigenen Agenda. Ich hoffe. Junge, alle sitzen da jetzt und sagen, Weihnachten ist weg, was wird Apple tun, they will listen. Ich meine, die sind nie blöd. Also werden sie sich irgendwas ausdenken, was einfach noch, naja, naja, so finde ich schon.
Das andere zuhören eben.
Ja, das wissen schon, ich meine, dass sie zuhören müssen, das wissen sie. Und ich finde, sie hören halt auch zu. Sie hören vielleicht nicht jedem zu, aber es ist auch nicht so, dass sie auf ihren Ohren sitzen würden. So, und ich meine, willst du mir noch nicht erzählen, dass Steve Jobs nicht weiß, wie seine Ansprachen wirken? Das eigentliche Mysterium ist das, was sie ja geschafft haben, durch diese Doppel-Ankündigung ein bisschen in den Hintergrund treten zu lassen. Warum ist jetzt nicht Steve Jobs auf der Keynote das erste Mal seit, ich weiß noch viel.
Also ich glaube nämlich, dass der, also die haben nix anzukündigen.
Also nicht im Januar jedenfalls.
Es wird wahrscheinlich sowas sein wie ein neues iLife, solche Yorner, neuer Mac Mini, überarbeiteter iMac, Mobile Me ein bisschen tollerer, ja vielleicht auch ein neuer Mac Pro, mit Displayport und irgendwie 20 MHz mehr, irgendwie sowas, wo dann alle sagen würden, oh das war aber eine langweilige Keynote und da hab ich mir mehr erwartet. Und überhaupt und Apple.
Da will Steve ja seinen Kopf nicht mehr herhalten.
Ja insofern nimmt er natürlich die Erwartungshaltung raus, niemand erwartet jetzt noch irgendeine geile Ankündigung.
Und vielleicht genau deswegen kommt die jetzt.
Jetzt erwartet es erst recht.
Ja und dann bringt es Phil Schiller.
Oh mein Gott ein iPhone mit...
Und dann ist er auch noch total cool.
iPhone Nano.
Oh man, okay wir sind in der Gerüchteküche. iPhone Nano won't happen.
Nee, glaub ich auch nicht.
Oder?
Ohne UMTS.
Was soll denn das bringen, die da Zentimeter weniger?
Apple will ja gar kein Telefon verkaufen. Die wollen denn, wie nennen die das?
Ja, kein UMTS.
Eine Plattform wollen die verkaufen.
Also dafür, dass sie kein Telefon verkaufen wollen bauen so verdammt viele.
Nee, aber nicht weil sie ein Telefon verkaufen, sondern weil die wollen die ganze Plattform halt mit den Spielen, mit dem Shop, mit dem das ist schön als Computer, also als Device.
Du musst jetzt mal das Gerücht, auf das du dich beziehst, nochmal erläutern.
Gerücht?
Naja, ein iPhone Nano.
Ich dachte, du hast es gerade in die Welt gesetzt.
Nein, nein, es sind ja diese Bilder veröffentlicht. Von diesem Cover. Von dieser Hülle.
Und der gleiche, die gleiche Stelle.
Was ja beim iPod Nano funktioniert hat.
Das hat nicht nur beim iPod Nano? Stimmt, beim iPod Nano hat es funktioniert.
Beim iPod Nano hat es halt genau gepasst. Da ist halt diese Blaupause von dieser Hülle oder die Hülle selbst, glaube ich, dann später sogar auf AIFA gesehen worden. Und dann war es halt genauso. Und jetzt soll halt so eine kleinere Version vom iPhone kommen. Bloß ehrlich gesagt, ich bezweifle einfach hochgradig, dass eine kleinere Version vom iPhone kommen wird aus vielen Gründen. Na, erstens glaube ich nicht, dass man durch das Weglassen von UMTS dort irgendetwas nennenswert kleiner machen kann.
Da hat doch Apple gar kein Interesse dran.
Die Geräte haben ja jetzt schon weniger Speicher als der iPod Touch, weil da einfach der Platz nicht reicht. Wenn das jetzt noch kleiner ist, was soll das? Außerdem geht die ganze Usability wahrscheinlich flöten, weil in dem Moment, wo der Bildschirm kleiner ist, werden auch die Pixel kleiner und das ist natürlich für die Fingerbedienung sehr wichtig. Die Programme sind darauf ausgelegt, von einer gewissen Mindestfläche auszugehen.
Aber der Bildschirm ist nicht extrem kleiner. Also ich meine, man hat die Bilder gesehen.
Ja, aber Apple sagt zum Beispiel, der Touch eines Fingers ist 44 Pixel groß. Das haben die auf dieser Veranstaltung gesagt, über die ich neulich berichtet habe. Das ist ein iPhone-Developer, der ja Antenne erzählt.
Aber das heißt nicht, dass ich das nicht morgen ändern kann?
Naja, aber das wäre schön doof.
Also ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass das einfach eine Marketingfrage ist, warum sie ein kleineres iPhone auf den Markt bringen. Also dass man einfach sagt, eins mit 4 GB Speicher ohne UMCS.
Das ist klein.
Das ist relativ klein, aber das ist für einen hier wahrscheinlich nicht klein genug.
Für Japaner? Mädchen?
Für Mädchen. Das Mädchen iPhone.
Aber da haben die doch gar kein Interesse an. Die wollen ihre Plattform verkaufen.
Weil das Preis ist ja für Metro 6.
Und wenn die das ohne UMCS verkaufen, kannst du nichts mehr damit machen. Das kann doch gar nicht im Interesse von Apple sein, dass ihre Kunden nichts mehr damit machen können. Die wollen doch nicht nur Telefon verkaufen. Da hat Apple nichts davon. Apple will doch den App Store haben. Die wollen die Programme verkaufen.
Die wollen die Spiele verkaufen.
Ich glaub auch nicht, dass Leute anfangen würden, ein iPhone zu kaufen, weil es kleiner ist und die es sonst nicht kaufen würden.
Na, ein paar gibt es bestimmt, aber jetzt...
Aber keine nennenswerte Zahl. Das bringt ihnen einfach keinen Markt zu gewinnen. Das ist nicht eine komplett neue Kundschaft, die sie jetzt auf keinen Fall kriegen würden. Das seh ich einfach nicht, von da ist das Quatsch. Maybe I'm proven wrong by Mr. Schiller.
Will sie?
Kann ja sein, aber ich glaub nicht, dass er da ist.
Ich hätt's nicht für komplett ausgeschlossen. Also das Display war auf den Coverhöhlen nicht wirklich viel kleiner, die ich so gesehen habe. Also wenn überhaupt. Und ich hab das immer so grob nebeneinander gehalten, aber das ist jetzt auch wirklich mehr eine Schätzung. Und ich kann mir vorstellen, dass es wirklich ein paar Leute gibt, die einfach ein kleineres, die das nicht wollen, weil es ihnen zu groß ist. Und man kann nochmal, man hat nochmal eine gute Begründung, sozusagen, warum, also weil es gab ja so Gerüchte um dieses 99 Dollar-iPhone, das dann nur 4 GB Speicher hätte. Aber wenn man tatsächlich ein deutlich kleineres Gerät hat, da kann man dann auch viel leichter begründen, warum das nur 2 oder 4 GB Speicher hat, dass man da irgendwie so viel Musik draufkriegt und sowas.
They won't go back. Die werden nicht... Die werden nicht downgraden.
Wir werden sehen.
Also da find ich die anderen Spy-Pics schon viel glaubwürdiger, wo ein iPhone mit 128 GB zu sehen ist.
Was? 128? Nein. Wofür?
Für Musik? Ich hab aber auch 160 GB iPods schon verkauft.
Ja, eine Platte aber.
Naja, aber Flash ist halt scheiße teuer. Naja, wird aber auch immer billiger. Und wenn einer gute Preise hat, dann Apple.
Ist noch nicht so weit.
I don't know. Wir werden sehen. Irgendwas wird kommen. Mehr Speicher ist auf jeden Fall gut. Ich hab derzeit einen 8 GB Phone, das reicht. Nicht wirklich.
Max hat jetzt 16.
Vati, hör mal kurz weg.
Ist schon voll?
Nee, ist noch lange nicht voll. Ich hab's gewagt, ich hab mir ein weißes.
Max hat ein iPhone. Ja, aber jetzt hast du ein richtiges Mädchen-iPhone gekauft.
Richtiges Mädchen-iPhone, genau.
Richtig UMTS mit O2, ja?
Mit UMTS und O2 und allem Pippa Po. Und da steht jetzt 3G.
Edge gibt's ja von O2 noch nicht.
Edge hatte ich schon vorher.
Hab ich auch gelesen, aber ich hab's noch nie gehabt.
Ich hatte das in den letzten Tagen.
In der U-Bahn oder wo?
Auf dem Dorf hatte ich schon.
Das will ich dir, wenn ich in der Stadt stehe.
Wenn man nach Brandenburg fährt. In der Stadt wirst du es nicht haben, weil die gesagt haben, dass es nur ausbauen muss, keine UMTS haben. Das hab ich die ganze Zeit über gesungen, als ich da war. Und ich bin doch sehr zufrieden.
Du hast das gekauft?
Ich hab's über diesen, das ging jetzt durch die Presse auch, diesen Retail Key Shop heißen die, die sind empfohlen worden von Simeo als Partnershop. Es ist offensichtlich ein italienisches Gerät, also ein grauen Port tatsächlich aus Italien.
Ist das eine Vermutung?
Nö, es gibt ja nicht allzu viele Merkmale, an denen man es feststellen kann, aber auf der Rückseite zum Beispiel steht die Beschreibung auf Englisch und auf Italienisch. Also jedenfalls nicht auf Tschechisch, ich vermute das Italienisch.
Und war es schon billig?
Es war nicht schön billig. Ich hab, glaub ich, knapp 650 Euro bezahlt. Nee, gut. Für die große Version.
Auf dem Altar von Steve Jobs.
Hab das verrechnet damit, dass ich für mein altes fast noch das gleiche kriege, was ich mal für bezahlt habe.
Ja, du bist ja auch ein Developer, du brauchst sowas.
Ich brauch sowas auch. Und ich wollt's auch haben. Und manchmal macht's auch Spaß, was Neues zu haben. Und solange man nicht rausgeht, hat man eigentlich nichts Neues, um ehrlich zu sein. Also im Haus hat man W-Lan.
Dann hat sich mal gar nichts geändert, außer mit dem GPS.
Und im Haus hat man ja auch keinen GPS, weil der Empfang ja eh zu schlecht ist. Aber sobald man rausgeht, ist 3G natürlich schon viel, viel besser. Also ich hab mal gestoppt, was ich dafür Datenübertragungs erreiche. Das geht ja durchaus im Bereich von kleinen DSL-Anschlüssen. Und über GPS, das war die Hölle. Das hat ja keinen Spaß gemacht. Und an dem Punkt ist es schon viel besser. Ansonsten, ein bisschen lauter ist der Lautsprecher, finde ich.
Bessere Qualität halt, ne? Hat ja viel bessere Qualität.
Der Lautsprecher? Ich glaube schon, ja. Also, Nersenlin ist lauter. Vom Design her, finde ich, das Alte war schon sexier mit dem Alu. Also mag ja sein, dass das vom Empfang her und so, aber irgendwie...
Na du hast ja auch ein Weißes gekauft.
Ja, ich hab mir ein Weißes gekauft.
Ich finde das Schwarze sieht einfach cool aus.
Schwarze sieht nicht cool aus, doch? Ich hab kein Schwarzes gekauft.
So sind sie. Jetzt haben wir hier das Gerät hier. Ja, jetzt haben wir alle drei da. Legen wir sie mal nebeneinander. Ich finde, man sieht echt am besten aus. Tja, kann sich jeder in seinem eigenen Apfel sonnen.
Ihr habt da so eine Plaste, wo man meint, das ist richtig stabil.
Ja, nee, das Ado ist schon auch schicker. Aber was ich so gehört habe, dass hier so die Kante, dass die so harsh sein soll, das ist aber bei mir nicht. Na so, dass da so eine kleine Kante zu spüren sein soll. Kenn ich Leute, die das so haben.
Wenn man will, kann man das irgendwie.
Aber von der Verarbeitung her war das alte eigentlich besser. Ein bisschen. Also hier sind es schon ein paar Sachen, die so ein bisschen rumplackern. Also die Tasten sind irgendwie ein bisschen loser und so. Und das ist... Aber...
Aber?
Ich hab keinen Tag ohne Jailbreak ausgehalten. Also es ist... Warum? Also zum einen wirklich tolles Programm, was mir noch nicht über die Füße gefallen ist, ist Status Notifier. Was heißt das, glaub ich? Oder Notify Status? Ich guck jetzt mal, wie das heißt. Und das zeigt nämlich oben in der Status-Leiste, das gibt's bei Sydia, zeigt das noch an, was man für neue Mails, dass man eine neue Mail hat, dass man eine neue SMS hat, dass man einen Anruf verpasst hat und dergleichen mehr. Und das, was du so beklagt hast, da sieht man, ob man abgeschaltet hat, ob man den Ton abgeschaltet hat, dann sieht man so ein kleines, durchgestrichenes Glöckchen. Find ich ein sehr, sehr schickes Feature.
Na gut, sieht man auch nicht, wenn der Bildschirm aus ist.
Sieht man nicht, wenn der Bildschirm aus ist, das stimmt. Dieses Wunder, den haben sie irgendwie nicht hingekriegt.
Da gibt's ja dieses Apple-Patent angeblich irgendwie. Find ich gar nicht so eine blöde Idee. Die wollen dann von unterm Display, durchs Display durchleuchten, durch so Art ausgeschnittene Löcher, die dann halt ein Symbol ergeben. Also eigentlich relativ billig, aber es soll ja eben auch nur funktionieren, wenn halt das Ding aus ist, dass man sehen kann, ob irgendwie eine SMS kam oder ein Anruf oder was auch immer.
Ja, dass man auch weiß, ob es überhaupt im Betrieb ist.
Ja, und ob sich was geändert hat. Weil so, man muss jetzt immer so mal klicken, irgendwie alle Viertelstunde, um zu gucken, hat man was verpasst, wenn man irgendwie einen Anruf erwartet oder eine SMS oder so.
Okay, es ist netter Fancy Stuff, aber ist jetzt nicht sowieso vorbei mit Jailbreak? Das 10.56 Update ist reingerauscht.
Der Jailbreak ist aber nicht vorbei, sondern man kommt nur nicht mehr mit dem Rechner in den DFU-Modus, wenn man das iPhone direkt an den Rechner anschließt. Wenn man aber einen Hub-Test macht, dann ist das wohl schon alles wieder okay.
Dennis hat recht, ich hab's ja unter 10.56 gemacht. Also es war so, dass ich das 10.56 Update habe ich installiert, also wurde auf meinem Rechner installiert, hat sich auf meinem Rechner installiert, während ich das iPhone abholen war. Und als ich dann zurückkam, als er das gelesen hat, ist Jailbreak nicht mehr möglich.
Dann dachtest du dir schon, oh Gott, alles ist vorbei.
Jetzt dachte ich schon, jetzt muss ich hier mit einem Jailbreak.
Aber eigentlich brauchst du auch gar keinen Jailbreak nicht unbedingt.
Ich brauch keinen, aber ich wollte diese Funktion haben, ich wollte dieses PDA-Net haben.
Achso, das geht nur mit einem Jailbreak-Programm.
Das geht nur mit einem Jailbreak.
Klar, deswegen bist du oben im Menü drin. Genau, deswegen bin ich oben im Menü drin.
Und dann dieses PDA-Net, mit dem man seine Internetverbindung über WLAN sharen kann, finde ich ja ganz angenehm. Und ich weiß nicht, ob ich es jemals nutzen werde. Das macht DHCP. Das ist wie eine Base Station. Ich richte hier ein Computer-to-Computer-Network auf meinem Rechner ein. Und verbinde mich dann mit meinem iPhone mit diesem Computer-to-Computer-Network. Und schon läuft alles.
Das heißt, man macht dann schon auch DHCP?
Der macht dann offensichtlich DHCP und alles.
Das ist PDAnet.
PDAnet heißt das. CrossFit Nix ist echt ein sehr, sehr schönes Programm. Und ich habe eine schöne, schnelle Internet-Verbindung damit, wenn ich mal eine brauche. Und das...
Hast du irgendwelche Nachteile durch den Jailbreak?
Ich weiß ja nicht.
Nee, nicht wirklich. Also ich wüsste nicht welche.
Na, ich habe es bei mir weggemacht, weil manchmal kam es mir so ein bisschen komisch vor und dann dachte ich mir, ach scheiße, brauchst du nicht, machst du mal weg. Und bin seitdem ohne. Also ich habe den Anlag noch, weil die Firma es halt gendert und oben drüber habe ich dann halt nur ein normales Update von Apple drüber gespielt. Funktioniert bisher.
Aber das mit diesem Notifier ist cool. Also ich meine, so Mails und so, könnte ich jetzt darauf verzichten, das funktioniert eh nicht, aber dass das Ding nicht anzeigt, wenn es gelockt ist, also wenn dieser Klingel-Ausschalter ist, habe ich ja letztes Mal schon beklagt, weil man kommt da ja auch sehr leicht ran, schiebst es in die Tasche, ist es auf einmal aus, vibriert nur kurz, aber selbst wenn du mal draufschaust, merkst du halt nicht, dass das greift.
Also einmal hatte ich einen Nachteil mit einem Jailbreak und da war das nämlich so, dass die installieren ja gerade mit diesem Cydia-Package, installieren die auch eigene Bibliotheken und da haben sie offensichtlich eine Version von SQlite 3 installiert, so tief im System drinnen, dass auch die nativen Programme drauf zugesgriffen haben und dann hat die Newsware plötzlich nicht mehr funktioniert. Das war dann irgendwie nach zwei Stunden behoben, das Problem, und dann ging's wieder. Aber das heißt, dass natürlich unter Umständen einige Bibliotheken nicht original Apple sind, die dann auch von nativen Apple Programmen benutzt werden.
Das war halt mein Gefühl, dass sie da irgendwie zu viel unten rumfuschen und ich da keinen Bock mehr drauf hatte.
Und welche Nachteile ich davon jetzt genauer habe, weiß ich nicht. Also ich weiß, was zum Beispiel die SMS-Applikation wird nach einer Zeit lang, wurde sie auf dem alten iPhone immer sehr, sehr langsam.
Das haben sie fix, weil es so viele SMS waren. Und jetzt zeigen sie nur noch die letzten 50 an, und wie auch immer, da ist oben so ein Button, das du nachladen kannst.
Ah, okay. Also war das vermutlich gar kein Problem, was ich durch den Jailbreak hatte, sondern ein allgemeines Problem. Insofern sind mir keine Probleme bekannt und ich bin damit sehr glücklich mit meinem Jailbreak. Jailbreak!
Ja, 10.56, jetzt sind wir ja schon dabei. Ist da sonst noch was Spannendes passiert? Mobile Me ist jetzt irgendwie, darf ich jetzt Push-Service nennen?
Jetzt jede Minute, ja?
Jaja, hab ich aber noch nicht ausprobiert. Also solange das mit diesem Kalender-Fu noch so ist, wie das da ist, hab ich ehrlich gesagt wenig Nutzen von meinem Mobile Me-Account. Also ich find den Dienst immer noch sehr unausgegoren und sehr unfertig. Das mag für eine bestimmte Zielgruppe ganz tolle Sache sein, aber das, das gewesen, was sie da drum machen, finde ich, ist noch nicht so richtig gerechtfertigt. Zumal sie ja jetzt hier auch ein aktueller Fall mal wieder eine Applikation abgelehnt haben, dieses Frugs für den App Store, die halt auch so ein Syncing mit Bookmarks und Pipapo ermöglichen und das ist halt jetzt abgelehnt worden, weil es eben Mobile Me zu sehr in die Quere kommt. Tja, und das obwohl sie ja jetzt auch wieder ein paar Applikationen zugelassen haben.
Sie haben ja eine neue Sparte aufgemacht, Entertainment.
Ach, es ist eine komplett neue Kategorie geworden.
Damit sie da die ganzen Schrott reinschieben können.
Ah, verstehe, das war ja nur ein reines Kategorieproblem, dass sie nicht wussten, wo sie die Putzgeneratoren hintun sollen.
Ich hab grad irgendwie Jet Sound, wird mir über IRC erzählt. Ich glaube, das ist der Blechdoseffekt, den ich vermutet habe.
Ein Jet Sound?
Ein Flanger Effekt.
Im Stream? Kann ich jetzt grade nicht so richtig überprüfen.
Das liegt wahrscheinlich daran, dass sie nicht...
Aber ich werde gerade verbessert, es sei hier nichts abgelehnt worden. Wieso? Was ist nicht abgelehnt worden? Diese Fruks-Geschichte ist doch abgelehnt worden oder nicht?
Doch, die ist abgelehnt worden.
Ja, also zumindest stand das hier in dem Blog-Eintrag auf blog.fruks.com la la la, they won't publish Fruks. Und dann gibt es noch hier ein Update, wo sie das so ein bisschen erklären und so weiter. Also das sieht doch sehr abgelehnt aus. Naja, auf jeden Fall tut sich ja eine ganze Menge, was diesen Upstore betrifft. Sie haben ja auch so das Layout im iTunes ein bisschen geändert und da haben wir ja über sich geschaffen und so die Top 10, die man ja schon auf dem iPhone immer abrufen konnte oder Top 50, was das auch immer ist.
Kann man jetzt auch im Store abrufen, ja?
Ja, ist da jetzt auch, wobei ich ja auch kein großer Freund bin. Es gab ja diese Diskussion ausgelöst von diesem Craig Hockenberry. So nach dem Motto, ach, die ganzen 1-Dollar-Ups, die kommen uns in die Quere und die sind dann alle so preisverkauft.
Ist halt so.
Na ist halt so, erstens das und zweitens, weiß ich nicht, ob das nun wirklich die Hauptquelle ist, weswegen Leute irgendwas kaufen.
Na ja, erstmal schon, aber man muss natürlich auch sehen, dass demnächst dann richtig, also der Markt ist jetzt natürlich erst mal frisch. Da kommen natürlich die ganzen kleinen Scheißerchenprogramme, wie das halt immer so ist, sondern das wird sich demnächst ein bisschen heben, weil dann haben die halt keine Chance mehr. Da gibt es zu viele von, kannst du kein Geld mit mehr verdienen und dann hören die Programmierer alle auf, so was zu schreiben. Und außerdem haben die dann vielleicht auch bessere Jobs oder machen dann vernünftige Programme. Die müssen ja erst mal warm programmieren. Und dann müssen die Leute halt auch mehr Werbung machen über ihre Webseiten, also nicht nur über den Store. Die verlassen nicht alle viel zu stark auf den Store und auf diese Top 10-Wertung und New und Aktuelle und meist gekauft, meist geladen und so weiter. Und das muss man ein bisschen davon weg, mehr zu so einer Art Version Tracker, Mac Update, wo da dann die Programme gelistet werden und zu deren eigenen Homepages halt, wo die Werbung dafür machen. Und dann korrigiert sich das alles so ein bisschen.
Ja, aber so was, ich meine, es gibt zwar so ein paar Sites, die versuchen das zu tracken, aber die kriegen ja nicht wirklich so Realtime-Data. Ich weiß gar nicht, wo die derzeit überhaupt ihre Daten beziehen.
Ja, aber bei Version Tracker klickst du natürlich drauf. Version Tracker kann schon so ein bisschen mitzählen und dann merken sie, wie oft geklickt wurde. Das geht natürlich.
Nee, was ich meine, ist, muss ja erstmal die Information haben, was wirklich in diesem App Store ist. Es gibt da zwar so RSS-Feeds und Pipapo.
Ja, aber das ist auch wie bei Version Tracker. Da müssen nicht die Leute bei diesen Update-Sites, wie Version Tracker auch, selber anmelden müssen. Da sagen, guck mal, hier, wir haben jetzt auch folgendes Problem, dass es noch ein bisschen mehr verteilt wird und nicht nur im App Store ist.
Also ich halte für ein großes Problem, dass es nach wie vor keine Demo-Versionen gibt. Also 80 Cent gebe ich aus, ohne mit der Wimper zu zocken, wenn ich das Programm halbwegs interessant finde. Das ist ja wie am... Ich weiß nicht, ob man noch mit Kaugummiautomaten steht oder sowas.
Da könnte man ein Demoprogramm ja jetzt prima machen, also hier so mit einem Monat for free. Und wenn du es dann weiter benutzen willst, musst du halt bezahlen. Das würde ja auf so einer geschlossenen Plattform relativ easy gehen, oder?
Das würde dann super einfach gehen.
Dann würde ich glaube ich auch ein paar mehr Programme haben.
Und das hält mich nämlich öfters davon ab, weil ich 20 Euro für irgendein Programm ausgebe. Da will ich eigentlich schon vorher wissen, dass es wirklich was Tolles ist und würde mir gerne mehr als fünf Screenshots angucken und irgendwelche Bewertungen von Menschen lesen, deren Bewertungen ich nicht unbedingt viel zutraue.
Ja, das stimmt. Also ich habe mir ein Programm gekauft, was ein bisschen mehr kostet und das war dann auch eher ein Flop.
Oder zum Beispiel diese 4 SSH-Version, wüsste ich jetzt nicht, welche ich nehmen sollte.
Bitte?
Von diesen 4 SSH-Versionen, wahrscheinlich sind es inzwischen schon noch mehr, wüsste ich jetzt gar nicht, welche ich nehmen sollte.
Aber gut, aber das sind eher so ein paar Dollar Sachen. Ich habe mir halt mal dieses Omni-Fokus gekauft, was irgendwie 16 Dollar kostet oder so.
Und das war nicht toll?
Nee, also es ist an sich ein, das ist schon ein ganz gut überlegtes Programm, aber ich fand, dass es mit Things gegenüber Things schon Nachteile hat. Hauptproblem ist aber, na, Things kostet 6 Dollar. Und auf ein Desktop kostet es nichts. Und Omni-Fokus...
Sinks auf dem Mac? Uiuiuiuiui, das wird nochmal richtig teuer. Das ist im Augenblick noch in der Entwicklungsphase.
Ja, und was soll das dann kosten?
Ich glaube 30 Euro oder sowas.
Ja gut, aber Omni-Fokus kostet 80 Euro. Und die iPhone-Version kostet 15. Das ist mir ehrlich gesagt für so To-Do-Kram dann doch ein bisschen zu happig. Also zumindest nichts, wo man mal eben so rein investiert. Ich war ja am Anfang so ein bisschen angetan von der Idee mit den Locations bei Omni-Fokus, aber am Ende hat das für mich nicht so gegriffen. Aber ich bin auch mit Things nicht vollständig zufrieden. Ich bin eigentlich mit nichts wirklich richtig glücklich derzeit.
Also alles andere hätte ich auch immer betrifft.
Aber...
Ach, wir waren bei 10.56? Ich hab ein neues iPhone. Ich hab die letzten beiden Tage nur mit dem neuen iPhone rumgespielt. Ich hab keine Ahnung, was ein 10.56 sein soll.
Also für mich liegt das Update irgendwie so ganz easy. Keine Beschwerden, gar nichts. Du hast danach irgendwie durchgebootet und eigentlich war nichts anders. Außer dass jetzt hier beim Energy Saver-Menü-Punkt hier oben, da wo die Batterie angezeigt wird, da kann man nicht mehr seine Spareinstellungen wechseln. Das geht nur noch in den Preferences selbst. Haben sie rausgenommen. Find ich, das ist ein Schade, wenn sie irgendwie Features entfernen. Oder irgendwie, weiß ich auch nicht. Und schon wegen der neuen MacBook Pros und MacBooks mit dem Touch-Trackpad. Das Kontrollfeld ist jetzt extra. Aber sonst? Da stand noch was so, dass die Grafik ist. Die Grafiktreiber sind ein bisschen, was haben sie geschrieben? Optimiert oder besserer zum Zocken? Ich hab mal wieder eine Runde WoW gespielt und mir kam es ein bisschen bunter vor.
Runter?
Nö, schneller würde ich gar nicht sagen, sondern so ein bisschen bunter. Ich hab das Gefühl, dass sie dann wieder irgendwelche OpenGL Features so mehr auch in Hardware unterstützen. Oder das muss von der API dann zur Hardware umgesetzt werden, dass das jetzt unterstützt wird und das vorher vielleicht einfach weggelassen wurde oder nicht so schick war in Software oder ein bisschen billiger dargestellt wurde oder so. Und jetzt kommt es mir ein bisschen schicker vor.
Verstehe.
Irgendwas haben die dann gemacht. Das hatte ich aber auch schon öfter mal. Vielleicht haben sie jetzt wieder irgendeinen API, die irgendwie jetzt in Hardware unterstellt wird.
Achso, irgendwas ist aus der Abteilung wieder nur halb gelesen und nicht richtig verstanden. Es geht bei diesem Fruchs überhaupt gar nicht um eine iPhone-Applikation, sondern es geht um eine Macintosh-Applikation. Und es geht um die Apple-Download-Seite. Also um sozusagen den...
Nee, bei Fruchs, da sollten die auch eine iPhone-Applikation rausbringen.
Ja, das wollen sie machen, aber darum geht's nicht. Was sozusagen moniert wurde, ist, dass Apple der Meinung ist, sie könnten das nicht auf der Software-Download-Page...
Aber Begründung ist zu einer Anmobilie dran, oder?
Genau. Naja, aber es bezieht sich halt auf eine Macintosh-Applikation. Aber es ist interessant, dass sie sozusagen an der Stelle jetzt auch querschlagen. Was ich ein bisschen albern finde. Das find ich ein bisschen albern. Das find ich wirklich albern, weil auf dem Mac, finde ich, sollten sie das nicht machen. Naja, vielleicht kündigt sich ja jetzt...
Auf ihrer Seite dürfen sie das. Also dagegen kann man wirklich nichts sagen. Also dagegen kann nicht mal ich was sagen.
Naja, gut, man könnte beim iPhone auch sagen, dass es ihre Seite ist.
Die Alternative ist das Ding.
Das stimmt, das stimmt. Nun ja, 10.56, was kann man noch sagen? Man kann sagen, dass man irgendwie seinen GPG-Mail, wenn man das überhaupt benutzt, aktualisieren muss. Gän, Schnarch. Naja, hab ich dann übrigens auch gemacht, hab auch nicht gemerkt, dass das irgendwie mal eine neue Version hat. Das Ding könnte auch tatsächlich mal selber eine neue Version checken, aber das ist wirklich auch echt halbfertiges Software. Aber immer noch die einzige Möglichkeit, genug PG oder GPG oder PGP auf dem Mac kostenlos zu nutzen und diese komische PGP-Produkt ist mir zu teuer und zu komisch.
Also es ist ja nicht nur teuer, sondern es ist ja nur für ein Jahr, ne?
Jaja, es ist so Miet-Software und so. Das guckt mir gar nicht auf den Rechner, also das hat keinen Sinn. Aber es gab ja auch noch Firmware-Updates, ne?
Ja, und zwar hört man ja, wenn man jetzt schon so ein paar Leute kennt, die ein neues MacBook oder MacBook Pro haben. Was hab ich da gehört für Probleme? Dass die nach dem Aufwachen irgendwie schwarz... Nee, Quatsch, falsch. Dass die beim Zuklappen, dass die irgendwie ewig brauchen, bis die mal schlafen, also bis die Lampe so anfängt, hier so zu vibrieren. Das dauert irgendwie ewig oder passiert wohl gar nicht. Weiß nicht genau. Ich hab nur gesagt, warte einfach ein bisschen länger. Und bei einem anderen Freund, der spielt auch WoW. Und dann macht's plötzlich Peng und der Rechner ist schwarz. Also er läuft wohl noch, aber der Bildschirm ist halt schwarz. Und da gab's dann Firmware-Updates, und zwar zwei Stück. Einmal, was waren das eigentlich für Updates? Für die Rechnerfirmware, also nicht das, was früher Open-Firmware war, dieses EFI-Zeugs, oder? Und das andere SMC, das, was für die Lüfter zuständig ist. Also glaube ich dieser Power-Management-Chip. Und es ist aber erst ein paar Tage her, deswegen habe ich noch nicht weiter gehört, ob es was gebracht hat oder nicht. Und dieses 4 GB Problem soll dadurch wohl auch nicht gelöst sein. Also kann ich eigentlich noch gar nicht genau sagen, ob nun was besser geworden ist oder nicht.
Das 4 GB Problem?
Da sind ganz viele Leute, die Probleme mit 4 GB Speicher haben. Da haben die doch gehofft, dass das mit einem Firmware-Update irgendwie...
Mit mehr als 4 GB oder mit exakt 4 GB?
Mit exakt 4 GB.
Wie in den neuen MacBooks? Mit 4 GB Speicher, aber die werden auch mit 4 GB Speicher ausgeliefert.
Nee, aber irgendwie eine Version wird mit 2 ausgeliefert, dann rüsten die Leute selber nach und dann haben sie 4 und dann läuft es aber irgendwie nicht so gut.
Oder sie haben das falsche RAM.
Irgendwie so. Aber sie meinen, dass wenn sie nur 3 reinpacken, mit auch einem von diesen neuen Riegeln geht's. Und wenn sie den anderen von den neuen Riegeln machen, geht's auch. Also so, dass beide okay sind, aber wenn sie beide reinmachen, dass dann irgendwie das immer rumzicken würde.
Na, wenn es halt ein identisches RAM ist, wird anders drauf zugegriffen als...
Ja, das könnte auch der Grund sein. Ich bin auch noch ein bisschen skeptisch, ob die Leute da genug Fachwissen haben, um irgendwie das so ordentlich auseinanderzufriemeln und so. Aber zum Beispiel der Kumpel, der hier WoW spielt und genau, hat dann auch plötzliche Reboots. Und einmal kam der Rechner dann wieder hoch mit so einem Könne-Panic-Report. Und da stand dann auch irgendwas von Deadlock in irgendeiner Routine. Also es könnte sogar auch ein Softwareproblem sein, muss gar nicht irgendwie Hardware sein. Das war ein bisschen, kann man noch nicht so sagen. Aber na, jetzt kam halt die Firmware-Update, jetzt kam ja kurz vor 10.5.6. Dann kommt jetzt noch 10.5.6 dazu. Das ist ja die erste Softwareversion, die jetzt wieder auf allen Rechnern gleich läuft, weil die neuen Rechner hatten ja erstmal so eine Zwischenversion, wie das halt immer so ist. Und da müsste man jetzt erstmal noch ein bisschen abwarten. Aber es ist ja immer so, wenn Rechner neu sind, da müssen die erstmal noch ein bisschen...
Ich hab ja schon mehrfach mein Einkaufswagen gefüllt.
Und geleert anscheinend?
Und wieder geleert. Und wieder gefüllt, wieder geleert. Und hab sehr mit mir gerungen, ob ich jetzt mir so ein neues MacBook zulegen soll. Und hab einen Rückzieher gemacht am Schluss. Weil du mich gewarnt hast. Wovor? Naja, vor den neuen MacBooks. Also es war jetzt nicht alleine ausschlaggebend. Es war mehr so ein Mosaik von Abwägungen. Einerseits war ich mir nicht so sicher, ob ich jetzt wirklich schon Firewire verlassen will. Auf jeden Fall. Und der Grund dafür ist tatsächlich die guten Erfahrungen, die ich mit diesem USB-Gerät habe. Interessanterweise. Also dieses Audio-Device, was ich vorhin schon beschrieben habe, ist von Mark of the Unicorn. Und eigentlich erkennt es sozusagen, welche Qualität diese, also MOTU heißen die jetzt kurz, Mark of the Unicorn, so waren sie früher bekannt. Und MOTU baut ganz offensichtlich geile Scheiße. Das ist meine Erkenntnis. Also dieses Gerät hat einfach eine Qualität und insbesondere dieser Treiber, obwohl ich auch schon Crashes gehabt habe, die auf diesen Treiber zurückzuführen sind. Jetzt nicht am laufenden Meter, sondern ich ziehe das Gerät im laufenden Betrieb ab und dann hatte ich so Frieses. Und wenn ich neu gestartet habe, kam so ein Colonel Panic Report drin, wo dieser Treiber explizit genannt wurde. Von daher gehe ich davon aus, dass es damit was zu tun hat. Das werde ich dir dann auch noch schicken. Okay, kann man jetzt sagen, ich bin eh kein großer Freund von, ich bin nicht von Social-Party-Treibern, aber das Ding performt wenigstens. Und im Bereich Audio-Treiber sieht es halt echt schlecht aus. Also Geräte, die performen, haben alle einen eigenen Treiber. Es gibt kein Gerät, was performt, was den Standard Core Audio Treiber Firewire oder USB nennt. Und das hat eine ganze Reihe von Gründen, die ich jetzt gar nicht alle aufrollen will. Tatsache ist, man ist sozusagen darauf angewiesen. Und dann habe ich mir nochmal das Line-Up von Moto angeschaut.
Das gibt es nochmal mit Firewire.
Ja, vor allem gibt es alles mit Firewire. Dieses Gerät ist sozusagen das erste, was es auch in einer USB-Variante gibt. Aber es gibt dann halt noch zwei größere Teile, die noch ein bisschen mehr Bank for the Bug haben und die zwar ein bisschen teurer sind, aber einfach nochmal so ein paar Dinge drin, wo ich mir denke, dass ich nochmal eine kleinere, coolere, mobilere Setup-Geschichte hinkriegen könnte. Ja, es gibt zum Beispiel das Ding in so einer 2A-E-Form, aber da habe ich dann auch gleich noch meine Mikrofoneingänge drin und so weiter. Das heißt, ich könnte hier unter Umständen, was ich derzeit auf vier Höhen-Einheiten habe, auf zwei runtergehen, aber dann ist halt Firewire angesagt. Obwohl jetzt gerade ein dicker Trend zu sehen ist im Audio-Markt, also zumindest im Low-Cost-Bereich und auch im Medium-Bereich kommen jetzt USB-Produkte. Mixer, die bis vor kurzem nur Firewire als Option hatten, kommen jetzt auf einmal in eine USB-Firewire-Mix oder nur USB-Variante und so weiter. Also man merkt, dass USB auf dem Vormarsch ist da. Ja, lange Rede, kurzer Sinn. Ich wusste dann nicht so recht, ob ich nun wirklich dieses MacBook der ersten Generation haben will oder ob ich nicht nochmal ein bisschen warte, wie viel von solchen komischen Fehlern da noch kommen.
Warum willst du dir überhaupt ein neues haben?
Ich will, weil es einfach weniger Lüfterbewegungen hat. Also dieses schwarze Teil bei der Auslastung. Ich hab halt immer so 10, 20 Programme laufen und immer fette Klötze und das Ding atmet einfach die ganze Zeit. Es ist einfach die ganze Zeit am Pumpen. Insbesondere wenn man noch Time Machine laufen hat. Die Platte ist groß, viele Dateien. Das Ding ist eigentlich mehr oder weniger die ganze Zeit am Backupen, hat immer irgendwie 50 Prozent CPU-Last. Und es ist halt einfach laut. Und wenn ich irgendwas hasse, dann sind es laute Computer. Das hab ich schon immer gehasst. Und mir ist es einfach zu laut. Und deswegen hätt ich gerne das neue MacBook. Weil ich gehört habe, dass das definitiv leiser ist.
Mehr Power, bisschen nicht so laut und...
Na die kriegen einfach ihre Hitze da besser weggeschaufelt und das Teil pumpt nicht so viel hin.
Ja, aber haben die da nicht auch geschrieben, dass wenn man es ordentlich benutzt, dass es auch ganz schön heiß wird?
Na es kann meinetwegen heiß werden, Hauptsache es wird nicht laut. Also mit heiß hab ich nicht so das Problem. Das einzige Problem, was ich mit heiß habe, ist, dass hier mein Tisch ein bisschen aus dem Fugen gerät hier.
Ach, das liegt an der Hitze?
Ja. Der spaltet sich hier in der Mitte, da wo der Laptop drauf steht. Da muss ich nochmal... Also du siehst, es gibt gute Gründe.
Du solltest öfter mal im Kaffee arbeiten.
Ja, von daher habe ich das jetzt für nach Weihnachten und mal gucken, was Phil Schiller so auf Tasche hat.
Naja, neue MacBooks werden jetzt erstmal nicht so schnell kommen.
Waren bei dem Thema...
Nö, das nicht, aber irgendwann kann es sein, dass es eine neue Hardware-Revision gibt. Dass Geräte ausgeliefert werden mit irgendeiner neuen Model-Number. MacBooks, ohne dass sie das groß announceen.
Ja, aber auch das wird jetzt natürlich eine Weile dauern. War doch mal so mindestens ein halbes Jahr circa.
Na, weiß man's. Also na gut, dann gibt es aber kein wirklich dringliches Problem, was sie nicht in Software gefixt bekommen. Dann kann man die Dinger auch kaufen. Aber ich denke mal, wenn es jetzt wirklich ein größeres Problem gibt, was sie nur durch eine Hardware-Änderung beheben können, dann werden sie das auch durch eine Hardware-Änderung beheben. Und dann werden sie nicht ein halbes Jahr warten.
Das ist richtig, aber glaube ich ehrlich gesagt nicht.
Na ja, dann warte ich einfach ab, bis die ganzen Software-Fixes durch sind. Keine Ahnung, vielleicht muss ich mir einfach nur noch ein bisschen sicherer sein, wie das mit Firewire weitergeht. Das ist halt eigentlich das, was wir wissen.
Das soll auf jeden Fall ein MacBook sein und kein MacBook Pro.
Na ja, das war dann auch das, was ich überlegt habe, weil ich würde sowieso mir das größere MacBook holen. Und dann ist natürlich die Preisdifferenz zum MacBook Pro jetzt auch nicht mehr so mega. Es ist halt nur diese Größe und Schwere.
Wenn ich bei dir schon höre, 20 Programme offen, und du bist ja auch so ein Vielnutzer und so, dann das ist doch der Grund für ein großes Display.
Ich habe mit dem Display eigentlich kein Problem.
Und das machst du auch nur alles ohne Spaces?
Mir geht es nur um RAM und CPU. Das ist das MacBook ja wunderbar. Ich mache das auch ohne Spaces. Ich arbeite halt immer mit einem Programm. Ich bin mit Apfel Tapp und Launchbar sehr glücklich. Ah, Launchbar. Wir sollten über Launchbar reden. Beta 5? Ja, weil auch nochmal danach gefragt wurde. Und weil wir das auch schon 1000 Mal angekündigt haben, dass wir nochmal darüber reden. Und jetzt gibt es gerade wieder eine gute... Ich bin ja einer aus dem Launchbar-Lager. Ich gehöre zu den Leuten, die...
Ich glaube, du bist das Launchbar-Lager.
Ich bin definitiv nicht das Launchbar-Lager. Es gibt noch andere. Ihr seid ja nicht das Launchbar-Lager.
Doch, doch. Ich hab's mir gekauft. Irgendwann die Vierer. Ich hoffe, dass die Fünfer noch...
Also mir ist nicht klar, wie man einen Macintosh benutzen kann ohne Launchbar. Das erschließt sich mir nicht mehr.
Da ist wirklich eine Menge dran.
Das ist einfach das erste Programm, was ich installiere, auf einem neuen Computer. Punkt.
Launchbar ist schon ziemlich...
Das denke ich, sagt eine ganze Menge aus. Und dann gibt's halt so die Leute, die meinen so, ach wieso, aber es gibt doch Quicksilver. Das stimmt, es gibt Quicksilver. Nur, ich weiß nicht, also, wenn man mit Launchbar gearbeitet hat und dann mal versucht, in Quicksilver dasselbe Verhalten zu erzwingen, das gelingt, das ist mir mehrere Male nicht gelungen. Also, für die Leute, die jetzt gar nicht wissen, worüber wir reden. Launchbar ist, wie der Name schon nahelegt, ein Launcher, das heißt ein Programm, was man möglichst nach dem Login gleich startet, dass es immer verfügbar ist, was man mit so einem Shortcut schnell aufrufen kann.
Ist das also eine Luxusversion von Spotlight?
Nee, es ist gar nicht Spotlight, es sucht nicht.
Sondern es findet nur.
Genau, es findet nur. Es ist, also der sucht halt, der indiziert. Das heißt, du sagst launchbar, was er sich alles anschauen soll, was er indizieren soll. Das können Files und Folders sein, Programme. Das kann aber auch dein Adressbuch sein und eine ganze Myriade.
Er lenkt sich auch so über die FS-Events irgendwie so rein und kriegt dann nochmal Updates und andere Änderungen.
Nein, nein. Also nicht, dass ich, vielleicht weiß ich nicht, ob die neue Version sowas macht, aber...
Schau ihn mal nach, er kriegt offensichtlich mit, dass sich was geändert hat im Application-Ordner und initiiert und dann zwischendurch...
Also ich weiß nicht, ob er mittlerweile FS, ob die neue Version das macht, die alte hat das meines Wissens nicht getan, ist auch nicht so schlimm, weil das, was man damit aufruft, sind nicht Sachen, die sich häufig ändern. Also während du Spotlight benutzt, für wirklich, was weiß ich, eine E-Mail mit einem bestimmten Inhalt finden. Die unter Umständen auch erst... Ja, aber das würde mir viel zu lange dauern.
Launchbar ist richtig, richtig schnell.
Launchbar ist so scheiße schnell. Also Spotlight, da hat Spotlight ja noch nicht mal angefangen zu rotieren. Da hab ich das Programm ja schon längst da.
Aber bei ihm ist jetzt Spotlight tatsächlich relativ schnell, zu meinem Erstaunen.
Auf meinem Computer warte ich erst mal zwei Sekunden, bevor Spotlight überhaupt erst mal anfängt nachzudenken. Und der Punkt ist, du kannst mit Spotlight bestimmte Sachen nicht finden, die Launchbar findet. Und vor allem...
Launchbar lernt dazu, das ist das Wichtigste.
Es lernt dazu und es lernt vor allem auf eine kluge Art und Weise dazu. Nämlich, das ist auch, wo ich finde, der Unterschied zu Quicksilver. Quicksilver lernt nicht gut. Das ist immer das Problem, was ich mit Quicksilver gehabt habe. Und wer halt meint, wieso soll ich denn Launchbar nehmen? Ich hab doch Quicksilver, dem kann ich halt nur sagen, Launchbar lernt besser. Das ist einfach die Grund, Kern, Funktionalität von Launchbar.
Die gibt's ja beide schon ziemlich lange, die Programme, was man ja auch schon an der Version 5 jetzt bei Launchbar sehen kann. Ich kann mich noch erinnern, als irgendwie mal früher Launchbar 2 rauskam oder das ist schon ewig her. Welches Programm war eigentlich zuerst von den beiden? Launchbar oder Quicksilver?
Ich glaub Launchbar.
Und dann kam aber Quicksilver und dann haben alle gesagt, boah, ist ja noch coolerer, kann das sein?
Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee. Wir haben über Launchbar schon vor Ewigkeiten mal gesprochen. Und zwar war das in dem Zusammenhang, ich weiß nicht mehr an welchem Zusammenhang, aber auf jeden Fall hab ich da erwähnt, dass es schon zu Next-Step-Zeiten existierte. Also schon richtig, richtig, richtig. Und Quicksilver?
Ihr hattet ja da nachgeguckt, da war mal.
Genau.
Kann gut sein, ja.
Und Quicksilver ist jetzt erst relativ frisch. Ich weiß nicht, ob da eben schon Version 1.0 sind. Das kam in dem Maße, ich glaube wahrscheinlich so ein bisschen aus, oh Mensch, Launchbar ist super, aber kostet viel Geld, also probier ich mal eine kostenhose Version davon zu machen.
Quicksilver hatte auch eine etwas andere Vision. Quicksilver hat sich mehr so als ein offenes Framework verstanden, um generell so eine Launch-Funktionalität in die Macintosh-Welt reinzutragen, mit Plugins und so weiter. Aber da hat nie genug angedockt, um das jetzt wirklich so interessant zu machen. Während sich Launchbar eigentlich immer wirklich nur auf die Kern-Funktionalität konzentriert hat, und da meiner Meinung nach eben auch gewinnt. Das heißt, sie haben sich einfach selber immer irgendwas gesucht, was man jetzt auch noch launchen könnte, und das haben sie einfach integriert, und das funktioniert dann auch gut. Während so diese, wenn du erstmal anfängst mit Abstraktionen und Plugins, dann kommst du halt auch schnell in hakeliges Interfaces. Und bei Quicksilver habe ich einfach viel zu oft in irgendwelchen Untermenüs, und nochmal Cursor rechts und hoch und runter, und wusste dann schon gar nicht mehr, wo ich war. Das mache ich bei Launchbar eigentlich nie. Was ich also, vielleicht mal so zwei, drei Features noch, die ich wirklich klasse finde und die ich regelmäßig benutze. Also für mich ist vor allem, also zwei, also abgesehen von dem Starten von Programmen, gibt es zwei Sachen, die ich regelmäßig benutze. Das erste ist Nachschlagen im Adressbuch. Launchbar hat nämlich so ein Konzept des sogenannten Subselects, was ich sehr cool finde. Wenn ich jetzt nach irgendeiner Applikation suche, möchte ich eigentlich nicht, dass irgendwelche Einträge in meinem Adressbuch, weil da sind so einige drin, mir dazwischenkommen. Und die würden mir am laufenden Meter dazwischenkommen, wenn man so komische Abkürzungen macht. Weiß ich einfach, wann ich in meinem Adressbuch suchen will und wann nicht. Also, ich starte Launchbar bei mir immer mit Ctrl-Space. Dann kommt halt dieser Bar unter der Menüzahle so runter. Das ist auch sehr, wie soll ich sagen, sehr unaufdringlich. Und dann wartet er eben so auf meine Keys. So, dann tippe ich A und das ist halt Adressbuch. Hat er gelernt. So, dann drücke ich Space. Und Space heißt Subselect. Nach dem Motto, jetzt habe ich es schon gefunden. Also würde ich Return drücken, würde er mir das Adressbuch starten. Jetzt drücke ich aber Space und das heißt, jetzt habe ich noch mal eine Eingabe-Runde für eine Abkürzung. Nur, dass er jetzt nur innerhalb des Adressbuches sucht. Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt deine Telefonnummer haben will, drücke ich Ctrl-Space, A, Space, D, A. Ja, jetzt habe ich hier schon irgendwie Dennis Ahrens vor meiner Nase. Ich bin aber immer noch in Launchbar. Ich kann jetzt über den Cursor rechts machen. Dann sehe ich hier, kann ich dir mal kurz zeigen, sehe ich hier irgendwie schon deine Kerndaten. Nochmal zwei Tasten runter ist deine Telefonnummer. Drücke ich Return, ist deine Telefonnummer groß und fett über meinem ganzen Bildschirm angezeigt. Extrem praktisch. Und ich kann natürlich auch alles gleich mit Copy und Paste daraus holen. Also das ist einfach verdammt praktisch und vor allem verdammt schnell. Also ich kann auf alles in meinem Adressbuch in 0,0 nichts zugreifen und vor allem blind. Also ich muss nicht auf den Bildschirm gucken, während ich irgendwas nachschlage. Ich kann wirklich... Und dann gucke ich hin und dann ist das Ergebnis da. Die zweite Sache...
Guck mal, ob ich das auch mit nur...
Du musst dann allerdings in der Konfiguration von Launchbar... Achso, das ist jetzt gar nicht installiert, ne? Also Spotlight bietet überhaupt dieses User-Interface nicht, von daher kann das so gar nicht funktionieren. Bei Spotlight suchst du halt immer nur global nach irgendwas. Und dann musst du immer wieder refinen, dann hast du eine E-Mail, wo das gleiche drin steht.
Aber den ersten Hit, wenn ich also deinen Namen eingebe, ist der erste Hit, ist halt so ein Adresskärtchen. Und wenn ich da draufklicke, öffnet sich das Adressbuch und der geht direkt zu deinem Eintrag.
Und das dauert aber eine Weile. Du musst das ganze Programm launchen, genau, dann geht er da hin, dann musst du auch nochmal gucken und scrollen und Copy und Paste machen und so. Und das ist auch alles... Mit Launchbar geht's halt... Klar, man kann das auch mit Spotlight machen, das ist nicht der Punkt. Launchbar verkauft sich dadurch, du kannst es blind machen und du kannst es schneller machen. Also es macht einfach alles schneller. Es gibt sogar drei Sachen, die ich hervorheben muss. Die zweite Sache, die ich benutze, sind, du kannst dir Search-URLs zusammenbauen.
Dass der dann gleich irgendwo sucht.
Genau, wenn ich in der Wikipedia was nachschlage... Ich hab die Deutsch und die Englische drin, die Englische spreche ich über EN und die Deutsche über DE an. Das heißt, ich mache CTRL SPACE DE SPACE...
Suchbegriff return.
Suchbegriff return. Bumm, macht er die Seite auf. Ich kann im Launchbar auch gleich sagen, ob er mir das mit UTF 8 oder mit Latent 1 entcoden soll, sodass auch eine korrekte URL dabei rauskommt. Und in der Wikipedia was nachschlagen, verstehst du, ich muss nicht erst Safari starten, neues Fenster aufmachen, URL eingeben, zeigt er mir die richtige Eingang, sondern ich bin einfach sofort da.
Aber er öffnet dann auch eine Safari Seite?
Den Default Browser. Das benutze ich nicht nur für Wikipedia regelmäßig, sondern das benutze ich auch für Amazon, chefkoch.de, Dick.cc, eBay, genau. Also alles, wo man irgendwie suchen kann. Und wo ich auch regelmäßig suche, Mac Update, so eine Sachen, Your Favorite Torrent-Site, Tiny URL, so eine Sachen, kann man halt einfach damit ganz schnell machen. YouTube, you name it. Das ist eine der Sachen, die ich ganz häufig nutze. So, was war jetzt das dritte, was ich noch als besser als geschnittenen Brot verkaufen wollte? Jetzt hab ich es wieder vergessen.
Ich vermute mal, abzellehrtaste lang gedrückt hat lassen. Also das ist für die besagte Suche bei Websearch. Wenn man einen Begriff hat, gerade bei Leo zum Beispiel, ist das ganz praktisch. Man will irgendein Wort sich übersetzt haben, man klickt das doppelt an, dann wird es ausgewählt, in Safari zum Beispiel, dann drückt man abzellehrtaste und hält die Leertaste lange gedrückt. Und dann schiebt er das Wort schon in so eine Art Zwischenablage, wie nennt man das? In Launchbar direkt rein, dann braucht man nur noch eins zu tippen, Leo, Return drücken, fertig. Und er ruft die entsprechende Seite auf.
Das heißt, der Launchbar zeigt das übersetzte Wort an und muss noch nicht mal die Safari-Seite öffnen?
Die Safari-Seite muss er schon öffnen, aber...
Du musst es nicht mehr reinpasten, sondern er übernimmt die Selektion. Das ist etwas, das gibt es erst seit einer... erst seit Kurzem. Das ist etwas, was ich schon immer mal mir angewöhnen wollte, es zu nutzen, tue ich aber derzeit noch nicht, weil ich mit Copy und Paste immer so fix bin.
Das ist halt, wenn da gar keine Safari-Seite mehr öffnen würde, für Übersetzen, weil Übersetzen ist doch eigentlich easy. Soll ich sie irgendwo holen und mir gleich, ich tippe irgendwie ein Löwe und dann kommt halt Lion, zack.
Da gibt es doch diese unglaubliche Absicht.
Das mache ich wiederum mit Spotlight. Da habe ich irgendwie diese neuen Dictionary-Plugins drin, so Tesaurus.
Der übersetzt.
DickCC gibt es auch als Dictionary.
Dass man in Spotlight rechnen kann, wisst ihr ja. Neun plus fünf und dann zeigt das Ergebnis gleich an.
Das kann man im Launchbar zum Beispiel.
Das kann auch Launchbar, genau. Aber jetzt gibt es noch ein Feature, was ich ganz regelmäßig benutze. Und das ist wirklich cool. Alle Programme, die sich korrekt wie Macintosh-Programme verhalten. Ihr kennt ja dieses Open Recent. Und wenn die Programme richtige Coco-Programme sind, die das nicht irgendwie anders machen, wie zum Beispiel Ableton Live das anders macht oder Adobe das anders macht, natürlich. Richtig, richtige Programme halt. Dann steht diese Recent-Items eines Programms sozusagen auch anderen Programmen zur Verfügung. Und das nimmt sich launchbar. Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt in Numbers oder in Pages, typische Programme, wo man sehr unterschiedliche Dateien hat, wo man aber dann auf ein Dokument, mit dem ich gestern gearbeitet habe, zugreifen möchte, dann ist das unter Garantie noch in den letzten 10. Das heißt, Ctrl-Space, Num tippe ich für Numbers und dann kann ich einfach, bevor ich Return drücke, drücke ich Cursor rechts und dann kriege ich die Recent Files. Kann mir da das File aussuchen, zack, Return und dann öffnet er mir das Programm gleich mit der Datei. Was gerade bei solchen Programmen wie Numbers, die dann immer mit so einem Default-Dialog, wo man versucht, nach deinem Template hochzukommen und so, sehr entspannt ist. Das heißt, ich suche nicht in Spotlight nach der Datei.
Du sagst schon gleich den Typ an.
Sondern ich sag einfach, ich will in Numbers dieses Dokument aufmachen. Und das geht auch ratzefatz.
Da müsste man in Spotlight, glaube ich, keinen Doppelpunkt unter Num eintippen oder irgendwie so. Weil man kann ja in Spotlight auch den Typen schon mitnehmen.
Ja, aber keinen Doppelpunkt. Ich meine, bin ich unter Unix oder was? Also das geht gar nicht.
Was ich an der neuen Version, an der 5er jetzt ganz hübsch finde, ist ein Feature, das nennt sich Clip Merge. Das soll, und zwar kann man dann, man kann direkt in der Zwischenablage mit einem, also man drückt zweimal Apfel C kurz untereinander. Und dadurch wird das neue, was man kopiert, direkt mit an die alte Abkürzung hinten dran geschrieben.
Das Feature musste ich ganz schnell wieder ausschalten. Weil? Weil es, ich weiß nicht, ob das immer noch so ist, aber ich hab das sehr häufig, dass mein Mac einen Ctrl C nicht nimmt. Kennst du diesen Bug auch?
Nee.
Hab den nur ich? Ich hab den.
Und darum hast du dir angewöhnt, einfach immer zweimal direkt...
Ich drück manchmal einfach zwei-, dreimal Kopie C. Damit es einfach richtig ordentlich auch im Clipboard steckt.
Und nicht nur so...
Was ich gerne hätte, ist... Ich hätte gerne einen Swap. Also das, was im Clipboard ist, dahin kommt, was ich gerade selectet hab und das, was selectet ist, ins Clipboard kommt.
Zum perfekten Clipboard.
Gibt's das nicht jetzt in Launchbar? Weil sie haben in Launchbar jetzt nämlich einiges... Die haben aber jetzt genau... Die haben eine Clipboard-Historie eingebaut. Das heißt, du kannst sozusagen auf deine letzten zehn Clipboard-Items zugreifen.
Aber aus der wünsche ich mir noch was.
Und ich glaube, da gibt's auch dieses Swap-Geschichte. Da bin ich jetzt gerade ein bisschen hilflos.
Das will ich seit... Ja, also ich hab mir nämlich mal überlegt, wie könnte so dieses perfekte Clipboard-alte Funktion... Man hätte ja gerne History, dass ich eine Sache kopieren kann, dann kann ich mir noch eine andere Sache hinterher kopieren, dass er sich irgendwie letzten hundert Sachen merkt, die ich mir irgendwann mal in die Zwischenablage kopiert habe. Und es gibt ja ungefähr 500 Programme, die genau das machen, aber keins funktioniert so wirklich super, wenn man das dann wieder einsetzen will aus der Zwischenablage. Sondern muss man irgendwie immer rumklicken und ein Programm und ein Fenster, und irgendwie total nervig. Und ich hab mir mal überlegt, dass eigentlich die perfekte Lösung dafür wäre, dass wenn man... Und zwar, wenn ich kopiere, dann brauch ich das Programm ja gar nicht zu sehen. Dann wird das einfach immer mit auf den Stack oben draufgepackt. Und wenn ich es dann einsetze mit Apfel-V, hab ich die ganz normale Apfel-V-Funktion, wenn ich aber nach dem Drücken von Apfel-V einfach die Apfel-Taste nicht loslasse, dass dann sowas wie so bei Apfel-Tab eingeblendet werden würde. So eine...
Dass man auswählt.
Dass man auswählt, damit V so...
Das hättest du gerne.
Das hätt ich gerne. Ich glaube, das wäre hyper intuitiv. Kann das nicht mal jemand schreiben von euch? Ich würd's... Ich würd's auf jeden Fall haben.
Was ich noch gerne hätte, ist ein Clipboard, also mehrere parallele Clipboards. Also ich hätt gerne, wenn ich irgendwo Text in mein Clipboard hole und dann sehe, aber ich will jetzt mal das Bildchen von da nach da kopieren, dass mein Text im Text-Clipboard noch drin ist. Weil das eine ist ja für Bilder, das andere ist für Text. Das muss nicht das gleiche Clipboard sein.
Das ist total doof. Das wär mit meiner Historie viel, viel besser. Badge.
Wieso? Das kann man auch parallel machen.
Jetzt kommt's mal alles raus, was man schon immer am Clipboard scheiße fand. Mich nervt nämlich noch was anderes, wo wir jetzt gerade so am Wunsch... Wünscht ihr was? Ist ja Weihnachten jetzt.
Oder so ein Clipboard-Stack. Ich hol mir ein Text rein, ich hol mir ein Bild rein, dann pump ich erst das Bild wieder irgendwo rein und wenn ich's nochmal mache, kommt der Text wieder. Naja, wahrscheinlich kommen die Leute da voll durcheinander, weil...
Also bei Launchbar gibt's eine Stack-Operation für Clipboard. Last in, first out.
Weil ich meine, eigentlich, wenn man dieses Programm technisch nicht mal anguckt, dann kann man ja im Programm sagen, wenn du zum Beispiel so einen Input-Teil hast, also du was aus dem Clipboard annehmen kannst, dann kannst du ja schon sagen, welchen Typen du annimmst. Also ob du Bilder annimmst oder Text oder was auch immer. Und der kann sozusagen schon entscheiden, ob er Text oder Bilder annimmt. Und deswegen könnte man eigentlich auch das schön mit dem Text und mit dem Bild trennen. Dass die sich unterschiedliche Sachen reinholen.
War jetzt ein bisschen blöd erklärt, ne?
Ich weiß noch nicht ganz genau, was du meinst, aber vielleicht hat es auch was damit zu tun, was mein Problem ist. Ich habe nämlich immer das Problem, ich kopiere mir irgendwo Text. Und der ist dann styled. Und dann paste ich den irgendwo rein und ich möchte definitiv ihn nicht gestyled haben. Aber er ist gestyled.
Na dann nimmt das Programm halt styled input an.
Genau. Wenn ich zum Beispiel aus meiner Email was kopiere, auch wenn es irgendwie eine normale als Text formatierte Mail ist, dann hat die aber sozusagen diese Formatierung. Also ich zeige mir extra nicht HTML-E-Mails an, sondern normale Text-Mail, damit das eben normaler Text ist. Dann kopiere ich das, aber dann ist es aber trotzdem styled Text mit der Formatierung, die das Mail gerade hat. Dann paste ich das irgendwie in mein Pages-Dokument rein.
Dann ist der Style immer noch da.
Und dann übernimmt er diesen Default-Style von Mail. Ich meine, geht es noch?
Was heißt geht es noch? Es gibt wahrscheinlich Leute, die es genauso haben wollen, die würden sich aufregen, wenn der Style weg ist.
Ja, aber so muss ich jedes Mal, ich habe Text-Mate laufen, nur als Clipboard-Cleaner. Ich paste dann immer jeden Text da rein.
Du sagst so Make-Plan-Text und nimmst es wieder.
Nee, ich brauch ja eine Text-Mate, wenn ich es da kopiere, sind die Styles weg. Dann sind die Styles weg.
Verstehe. Deswegen verkaufen sich so viele Text-Mate.
Also ich brauche nie...
Also ich nutze dafür mal BB-Edit.
Aber ich brauche nie Rich-Text. Ich brauche nie Style-Text, meine ich.
Nie, nie, nie.
Und ich würde das gerne einfach ausschalten. Hilfe. Phil Schiller, Hilfe.
Und ich bin halt, wie ihr schon merkt, weil ich auch keinen Launchpad habe, ich bin nicht so ein Fan von Third-Party-Applications. Mir ist immer zu viel Installations-Shit und so. Ich hätte gerne das alles gleich immer so tun.
Du willst die reine Lehre haben.
Dieses Copy-and-Paste geht dir total auf den Sack.
Nein, Copy-and-Paste ist cool, ist ja drin.
Nein, nein, ich meine dieses Kopieren und Einfügen von Programmen am Anfang.
Ja, das ist wahrscheinlich von früher. Ich hatte halt mal einen Amiga.
Der Installer ist sein Feind.
Ich bin auch so ein Programmschließer. Auf einem Amiga war alles ein bisschen limitiert. Da musstest du den ganzen Shit immer zumachen. Sonst ist dein System geplatzt. Deswegen mache ich immer schön alle Programme wieder aus, weil es irgendwie so drin ist.
Du beendest deine Programme?
Klar, immer schön sauber den ganzen Shit.
Was machst du dann, wenn du da mal einen Tag über mit so einem Dokument arbeitest? Machst du das dann alle 20 Sekunden wieder neu auf oder was?
Dann speichere ich das ab, das ist sowieso besser, weil sonst machst du nämlich plötzlich Peng und dann ist dein Dokument weg. Das ist genauso scheiße. Jedenfalls auf den Amiga habe ich immer lauter auch Zeug, was ist da nicht alles gehabt. B-Clock von diesem Matt Dillen zum Beispiel, den es ja immer noch gibt mit seinem Dragonfly-BSD und so und dann 1000 andere Sachen mit Opaq, Wind und ganzen Schneegeschnecken, den es früher gab, der heutzutage Standard ist. Aber wenn du dein System ganz oft neu installierst, weil du so ein Bastler bist, dann geht das irgendwann auf den Sack und dann hab ich irgendwann angefangen, das halt nicht mehr zu machen und mich mit den Standard-Features so zu beschäftigen. Auch mag ich es nicht, wenn ich an einen anderen Rechner komme. Ich hab mich so voll an mein Feature-Set gewöhnt.
Ja, aber dein Chat läuft doch auch die ganze Zeit.
Hier ist in einer Shell eine Konsole. Und Audio muss ich immer starten, ja. Find ich auch schlimm. Leute, den startest du. Und dann starten gleich 20 Programme und dann denk ich mir so, warum wird da jetzt Photoshop gestartet? Ich brauch gar keinen Photoshop und er braucht jetzt wahrscheinlich auch gar keinen Photoshop. Aber es wird erstmal Photoshop automatisch gestartet. Und das für so ein Programm, was irgendwie eine Minute braucht zum Starten, find ich ganz schön krass. Ja, was wollte ich gerade sagen? Ich wollte noch was anderes sagen.
Das weiß ich jetzt nicht.
Genau, dass wenn du dich so an so ein Feature Set gewöhnt, so wie du, du bist jetzt halt voll so in dem Spotlight-Quatsch, in deinem Launchbar-Dings drin. So, und dann musst du dich mal in einen anderen Rechner setzen und dann so drückst du deinen Control Space und dann ist groß sein Setzen nichts passiert. Und dann ist man noch voll aufgeschmissen.
Ich setz mich nicht an ein anderer Leute Computer.
Außerdem ist das doch total...
Ist wahrscheinlich inzwischen so wahr. Jeder hat seinen eigenen Scheiß.
Wenn jeder so denken würde wie du, wären wir niemals von Bäumen runtergekommen.
Ja, ich meine, wann hast du letztes Mal einen Computer von jemand anders benutzt? Ich meine, länger als, sagen wir mal, für eben mal eine URL eingeben.
Das liegt vielleicht daran, weil ich war immer Macintosh-Admin bei einer größeren Clicker-Bude und da musste ich mich halt um die Macintosh kümmern.
In der Zeit hab ich das auch so gemacht. Aber ich muss sagen, mittlerweile, ich mag Customization. Ich hätte auch kein Problem damit, wenn sowas wie Launchbar im Betriebssystem drin ist. Aber nur, weil Apple das jetzt noch nicht findet, dass man sowas Ähnliches einbauen sollte, heißt noch lange nicht, dass ich darauf verzichten möchte. Und so sehen das, glaube ich, auch die meisten Leute.
Also ich weiß schon so, ich hab das irgendwo gesehen, dass unter 10,6 das Spotlight noch ein Stück schneller wird. Aber ich glaube, das Spotlight ist auf dem neuen System immer erst mal ein Stück schneller.
Naja, ein neues System gibt es bei mir nicht. Ich hab halt einfach hier meine 100.000 Dateien irgendwie oder mehrere 100.000 Dateien und da muss er sich halt irgendwie durchkämpfen und der braucht da einfach zu lange für. Außen ist Spotlight.
Wir machen jetzt die Domino-Steine auf.
Domino-Steine.
Dieses teuerste Domino-Steine.
Ich war... Apropos Domino-Steine, die... Wollen wir nicht noch mal eine Runde Glühwein aufschicken?
Setz mal noch mal eine Runde Glühwein auf.
Ich fände ja, wenn wir den Max angucken, der hat schon richtige rote Backen.
Ich bin auch schon ganz glücklich. Ich war ja letzte Woche bei der Telekom zu Besuch. Um jetzt mal auf das Thema zu kommen.
Dennis.
Was? Und die haben nämlich hier ein neues...
Die haben nämlich ein neues...
Ich schalt gleich deine Spur aus. Das kann ich nämlich hier machen. Soll ich mal machen?
Telekom warst du.
Die haben nämlich ihr neues, ihr neusten heißen Scheiß vorgestellt.
Ich muss erstmal Dennis Spur ausschalten.
Die haben dieses Android.
Dennis will wieder rein. Aber nur wenn du nicht sofort schmatzt.
Bloß weil es um nicht Apple-Produkte geht, heißt das nicht, dass man nicht zuhören kann. So ein bisschen.
Wir waren eineinhalb Stunden durch, Jungs. Und der Glühwein zeigt schon erste.
Also bei mir zeigt man keine Produktion mehr.
Du warst bei der Telekom und die haben neue Produkte vorgestellt.
Ach du hast.
Die haben genau ein Produkt vorgestellt.
Dass er bei der Telekom war? Und dass es so schrecklich war und dass die gar nichts können. Das hab ich getwittert. Nee, ich follow dir gar nicht mehr, weil du so viel gespammt hast.
Ich hab das aber noch...
Webbeleidigung 2.0 sag ich nur.
Das war ja alles erst letzte Woche.
Ach so.
Was sag ich schon wieder?
Du warst ja schon mal bei so einer Telekom-Veranstaltung.
Ich war irgendwann mal, als sie ihr Telefon namens iPhone präsentiert haben. Da war ich dabei. Das war auch das letzte Mal.
Und jetzt haben sie halt dieses andere Telefon ausgestellt.
Dieses?
G1.
Ja, exakt genau das.
Und zwar...
Das Gu-Phone.
In einem hippen Telekom-Laden irgendwo in der Mitte.
Es gibt einen hippen Telekom-Laden?
1040 oder so, was heißt der?
1040?
Nur randvoll mit Apple-Produkten. Dieses arme Telefon war komplett umstellt von iPhones und iMacs.
Was ist ein Telekom-Laden mit Apple-Produkten?
Ja.
Was für Apple-Produkten?
iMacs, iPhones. Nein, nein, nein, nein, ich weiß nicht. 1040 heißt der, glaube ich.
Bis das von der Telekom.
Das ist von der Telekom, ich hab's nicht geglaubt. An manchen Stellen sieht man es sogar. Ich muss jetzt mal gucken, ob ich den hier irgendwo finde.
Ist egal, erzähl, wie es war. Jetzt kann ich aber keinen Glühwein aufsetzen, wenn du mir so was Spannendes erzählst. Das ist nicht noch ein langweiliges Thema vorher?
War das jetzt nicht genug langweilige Themen bisher?
So, Lucky Hit hoffe ich hier.
Telekom wäre vielleicht nicht schlecht gewesen. Und die anderen gab es, gab es so kleine Designerschnittchen, also Designerschnittchen zum Essen. Und Bier und so ein ganzes Zeug.
Du tust jetzt erstmal nur 5 Euro in die Schovi-Kasse, Dennis.
Wieso? Ihr habt mich hier abgefüllt mit Zeug. Hast du schon so lecker Domino-Steine?
Irgendwo müssen die einen rein.
Mach mal, die sind so lecker.
Ja, echt? Die Lebkuchen haben mich nicht ganz so umgehauen, muss ich sagen.
Nee, die waren ein bisschen trocken.
Ja. Das ist ja auch bio.
Ich find auch die Domino-Steine.
Das gehört so.
Diesen Schemo.
Findest du nicht gut?
Aber schmatze nicht ganz so laut, bitte. Und das war leider eine ganz furchtbare Präsentation. Also es ist übelstes Schwäbeln. Dafür kann der Mensch, der schwäbelt, hat nichts. Für seine blöden Witze kann er aber schon was, so Alternhumor, so ein bisschen da reingeschnitten in diesen Vortrag. Und es wirkte wie Powerpoint Karaoke. Also als ob der dieses Gerät zum ersten Mal sieht und sich spontan was dazu ausdenkt. Also keine Struktur drin. Aber das Telefon selbst ist ehrlich gesagt ziemlich schick. Ich möchte so ein G1 haben.
Das heißt, die Slides haben überhaupt nicht zum Produkt gepasst?
Sie haben am Anfang betont, das ist, wir machen heute gar keine Slides. Und wir haben nur da so ganz kleine Slides. Und hier haben wir die große Präsentation von dem Monitor. Das G1. Und die Slides waren dafür, dass sie sehr klein waren auf dem separaten Beamer, aber auch wirklich komplett zugemüllt mit irgendwelchen Schwachsinn, der überhaupt keine Rolle spielte. Ja, aber viel zu viel Text, also nicht irgendwie drei Punkten, sondern so die Vision der Telekom, die normalerweise auf 20 Seiten passt, auf eine Seite kopiert. Und dementsprechend fehlte dem Präsentator jeglicher rote Faden, um sich da irgendwie durchzuhangeln. Und... Internetflöten? Dadurch zog sich das ein bisschen hin, genauso wie meine Erzählung sich gerade so ein bisschen hinzieht und war nicht so ganz so spektakulär. Sie haben exakt nichts zum Gerät gesagt. Nämlich, es war kein deutsches Gerät. Ich glaube, die Sprache war auf Deutsch eingestellt. Vielleicht, bin ich mir aber ehrlich gesagt gar nicht mehr so sicher. Die Tastatur war auf jeden Fall eine amerikanische. Sie haben keinen Starttermin genannt. Außer 1. Quartal 2009. Sie konnten keinen Preis nennen, sie konnten keine Tarife sagen, sie konnten gar nichts zu dem Telefon sagen. Außer, wir haben es.
Und du weißt, dass du es haben willst?
Das ist ein schickes Telefon. Das Telefon ist nicht schick. Das Betriebssystem ist schick. Das Betriebssystem ist...
Dieses Android.
Dieses Android. Also es ist...
Was ist schick?
Wir haben ja alle die Fotos von dem Telefon schon gesehen. Es ist in Natura nicht halb so klobig wie auf den Fotos. Es sieht auf den Fotos immer sehr, sehr klobig aus und sehr, sehr groß. Da ist ja so ein kleiner Trackball zum Beispiel dran. Der ist ungefähr so groß wie der Nippel an so einer Mighty Mouse. Dadurch wirkt das Display dann auch viel feiner. Die Tastatur ist erstaunlich gut für so eine kleine. Wobei ich würde sagen... Ich weiß nicht. Ich ziehe mittlerweile das Softkeyboard von Apple vor. Aber das Betriebssystem ist eben ein schönes Betriebssystem, was relativ schnell ist. Die haben ja diese Status-Leiste, so ähnlich wie auf dem iPhone oben, wo auch dann drinne steht, wenn es irgendwelche Ereignisse gab. Dann kann man die mit dem Finger nehmen, kann sie so runterziehen, und dann kommt die so wie eine Stadiosie oben rausgefahren. Und dann sieht man da so die letzten Ereignisse, die stattgefunden haben. Also wenn zum Beispiel jemand angechattet hat, oder wenn eine neue Mail da ist, oder eine SMS, oder wenn man einen Anruf verpasst hat, das sieht man dann da oben. Das können sich auch andere Programme einklinken. Also wenn ein Download abgeschlossen ist, steht das da oben drin. Das ist zum Beispiel eine ganz hübsche Sache. Und es bedient sich sehr flüssig. Es bedient sich nicht so flüssig wie ein iPhone. Man hat mehr so Fragezeichen-Effekte. Aber die halten sich in Grenzen. Ich hab für so eine frühe Version von einem Hersteller, von Suchmaschinen, die noch nie ein Betriebssystem produziert haben, hab ich mit viel Schlüngung im Erwartung gerechnet. Es lässt sich relativ intuitiv mit dem Finger bedienen. Man muss hin und wieder mal die Tastatur aufklappen. Wobei das dann im Allgemeinen auf dem Display steht, hey, klapp mal die Tastatur auf, ansonsten kannst du nicht tippen. Also ich glaub, das wird eine schöne Plattform, die auch ein paar Sachen zulassen wird, die auf dem iPhone nicht möglich sind. Was ich zum Beispiel sehr schick find, das hab ich...
Netz zum Beispiel übers Telefon.
Was haben wir nicht drin?
Na so, dass du mit deinem Rechner dir das Netz von deinem Phone holen kannst. Ich mein, die haben halt UMTS, das ist irgendwie schon Richtung, so wie früher das erste DSL war, das ist schon ein ganz schön fettes Netz und dann kann ich mir so einsehen, warum mein Rechner das nicht nutzen können sollte.
Soweit ich gelesen habe, ist es zumindest nicht serienmäßig vorgesehen.
Beim Android. Ganz offen sind die ja auch nicht, ne?
Ganz offen sind sie auch nicht. Was es allerdings gibt, was ich jetzt gerade heute gesehen habe, das heißt, wie heißt das Programm? Olken, das ist so ein Grease Monkey für den Browser, der da drauf ist, auf dem Android-Phone. Und Grease Monkey ist ja so eine Erweiterung für Firefox, gibt es aber auch für Safari, mit dem man ein Programm um eigene JavaScripte, eine Website um eigene JavaScripte erweitern kann. Also wenn ich zum Beispiel jetzt irgendwie auf spiegel.de bin und da hätte ich gerne, dass da eine zusätzliche Suchfunktion ist oder dass alle Farben draußen sind oder dass die Überschriften größer sind oder weiß der Teufel was, kann ich eine zusätzliche Funktionalität reinschreiben in die Website, ohne dass mir die Seite selber gehört. Und da hat jemand eine sehr schöne Erweiterung geschrieben, mit der dann zum Beispiel solche Sachen wie auf irgendwelche Büchersuchseiten kann man dann, wo man den Barcode von einem Programm eingeben muss, kann man dann einfach einen kleinen Button klicken, der zusätzlich da ist. Dann geht die Kamera an und geht über das Produkt drüber, scannt den Barcode ein und ersetzt das direkt in das Textfeld ein, das Ergebnis. Oder, dass wenn man irgendwo eine E-Mail-Adresse eingibt, den Fernseher mit Yahoo Mail demonstriert, dass er dann die E-Mail-Adresse direkt aus dem eingebauten Adressbuch des Android Phones nimmt.
Barcodescannen funktioniert gut. Hast du das ausprobiert?
Also ich hab hier ein, da waren nicht so viele Programme drauf.
Diese Kamera, ist die denn deutlich besser als die vom iPhone?
Ich glaube, die sind im kurzen Bereich relativ besser. Also ich hab hier nur das Video gesehen.
Also dass das iPhone keinen Makro-Modus hat, das ist wirklich eigentlich das größte Problem.
Und ich glaub, das ist einfach im Nahtbereich besser. Und so eine Möglichkeit, gerade wenn man so ein bisschen JavaScript kann oder sowas, dann fallen doch gerade auf dem iPhone doch sehr viele Anwendungen ein, die man noch zusätzlich hinzuschreiben könnte.
Was nutzt ihr für einen Browser auf diesem Android?
Das ist ein Webkit, aber ich weiß nicht, wie der heißt. Sie nennen, glaube ich, Chrome, aber ich nehme an, der wird nicht viel mit Chrome zu tun haben. Aber auf jeden Fall ist es ein Webkit, was dahinter.
Ja, wir sehen jetzt hier gerade so ein Video, wie das G1 Barcode scannt und muss sagen, daran gefällt mir schon allein die Tatsache, dass das Programm in der Lage ist, während des Bildschirmeinblendens, also während des Kameraeinblendens sozusagen noch eine Maske drüber zu legen. Beim iPhone ist es ja derzeit so, du kannst halt dem Betriebssystem sagen, mach mir mal ein Foto und dann hast du währenddessen halt immer so nur diese normale Standard-Kamera-Oberfläche, aber kannst es eben nicht mit dem eigenen User-Interface dekorieren. Das nutzen sie ja dann auch für diese ganze Augmented Reality Geschichte.
Das Android ist schon deswegen nicht schlecht, weil es macht dem iPhone ein bisschen Feuer unterm Arm.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Also das...
Das hat durchaus das Potenzial dazu. Also das Betriebssystem wird dazu taugen. Und es ist, ich stand vorhin bei Kaisers, als ich unseren Glühwein gekauft habe, und dann stand da schon wieder jemand mit dem iPhone rum. Es gibt langsam zu viele iPhones da draußen, oder?
Ja, es gibt auch schon zwei.
Das kann nicht mehr lange.
Jetzt noch schnell auf Ebay, mein Freund.
Ja, wir sind hier so voll im Massenmarkt. Das geht zu Weihnachten schon. Das ist überhaupt nichts Besonderes mehr. Das ist total schlimm. Wir sind gar nicht mehr cool.
Bitte?
Wir sind gar nicht mehr cool mit so einem iPhone. Das ist schon ein bisschen traurig.
Also mit so einem Google-Phone ist man jetzt wahrscheinlich auch nicht direkt das, was man cool nennt.
Also ehrlich gesagt, ich hab mich mit anderen Apple-Produkten schon mal cooler gefunden als mit dem iPhone. Komische Aussage jetzt, ne? Aber ich bin nicht unbedingt davon ausgegangen, dass ich jetzt cooler rüberkomme, wenn ich ein iPhone in der Hand habe. Ungläubige Blicke.
Fragende Blicke eher.
Ich hab's mir erst ein Jahr nachdem es rauskam gekauft, da war das irgendwie schon normal.
Also früher saß du so in der Bahn irgendwie, da saßen die ganzen PC-Fuzzies da mit ihren Schlipsen und haben an irgendwelchen billigen Asus, IBMs, Dales, Tralala gesessen. Du hast dein schickes, silbernes MacBook rausgeholt, oder Powerbook hieß das ja damals, und hast deinen schicken MP3-Player, also ein iPod halt, und die hatten alle nur so eine Media, wie heißt diese Scheiße? Keine Ahnung.
M3164-X.
Ja, irgendwie so Medion, genau so. Irgendwie so am Hals hängen mit Kettchen, irgendwie dachtest du, das ist eine Scheiße. So und letztens irgendwie, ist auch schon wieder eine Weile her, aber du sitzt in so einer Bahn, packst deinen 15-Zoller aus, siehst du, wie so ein paar Sitze weiter, irgendwie so ein 13-jähriger, so so ein 17-Zoller auspackt. Von Apple. Und dann denkst du dir so, shit, guck da irgendwelche...
Das ist wie in der Werbung von Apple, als sie irgendwie das 12er und das 17er rausgebracht haben, mit den Basketballspielern.
Also du bist einfach nicht mehr cool. Mit solchen Produkten. Ne, das stimmt. Es ist vorbei.
Es ist jetzt Mainstream. Naja, aber ich meine, das ist auch gut. Oder sehens du dich jetzt? Ich meine, wenn du das Abenteuer, das keiner hat, meine Plattform haben willst, dann...
So ein bisschen ist das schon cool. Das findet man natürlich schon auch so ein bisschen toll. Ich muss ehrlich gesagt so die ganzen...
Was anderes installieren?
Die will ich gar nicht haben auf meiner Plattform. Die nüllen dann nur rum und jammern einen voll und haben auch irgendwie keinen Plan. Also die ganzen El Chipo User, die brauch ich alle gar nicht.
Jetzt ging, glaub ich, der Markteinteil von Apple schlagartig um 1% zurück, als du das gesagt hast.
Geil.
Nee, also so Massenmarkt ist nicht nur cool, weil Apple muss den auch bedienen und dann gibt's wieder keine coolen Special Features, weil sagen sie ja, nee, da kommen die User ja nicht mit klar und so. Das ist doch total schlimm.
Ja, aber auf der anderen Seite wünscht du dir auch immer noch mehr diversifizierte einzelne Produkte und das wird es nur dann geben auf dieser Plattform, wenn da auch die entsprechende Anzahl von Käufern dahinter steht.
Ja, das kann sein.
Also allein der Mac Mini ist schon so ein Produkt.
Wobei die größte Produktauswahl hatte Apple doch eindeutig zu den schlechtesten Zeiten.
Denn die war aber auch wirklich schlecht.
Ja, von Michael Chandler oder was war das? Mit dem Riesenquadrat? Nee, das war vorher. Riesenquadrat?
Egal.
Ja, so mit diesem Quadrat mit den vier Produkten. Aber das kam ja dann halt kurz danach, wo sie alles weggestrichen haben. Als sie gesagt, wir machen jetzt nur noch irgendwie kleine Computer in klein und groß und große Computer in klein und groß und das war's dann.
Tragbar und nicht tragbar.
Ja, irgendwie so. In dick und in dünn.
So, ihr könnt ja mal darüber philosophieren. Ob welche neuen Produkte auf der Macworld Expo vorgestellt werden und ich...
Dann macht ihr ja solange, setz dich auf.
Ach du setzt es auf.
Ich setz jetzt einfach auf. Ich setz jetzt mal auf.
Okay, du kannst da auch...
Kann ich deinen Domino-Stein haben?
Du kannst da...
Nimm den Domino-Stein.
Du kannst da sicherlich auch um Unterstützung...
Ich frag um Unterstützung ganz voran durch.
Ja. Dennis. Alter Domino-Fresser.
Was soll ich sagen?
Was sind die neuen Produkte auf der Macworld Expo? Glaskugel-Abteilung. Heute können wir das mal machen, weil wir haben sonst irgendwie nichts auf der Liste.
Also ich war ja noch nie so ein Fan von so Bild in den Rechnern, also so alles Komplettes. Also Mac Mini und iMac waren nie so mein Ding. Deswegen bin ich da nicht so richtig up to date und kann da nicht wirklich in die Glaskugel gucken.
Aber du weißt doch schon, was Mac Mini an Features hat und was ihm fehlt.
Ja, so ein bisschen. Und dass sie ihn schon seit anderthalb Jahren nicht mehr geupdatet haben und so. Das schreit ja förmlich nach dem Update. Aber ich würde mich jetzt auch nicht wundern, wenn sie das Ding einstellen und vielleicht irgendwas anderes rausbringen oder so.
Den werden sie nicht einstellen, auf keinen Fall. Ich meine, das...
Ich kenne ja die Verkaufszahlen nicht. Da wurde schon so ein bisschen unterrepräsentiert immer, oder?
Die Verkaufszahlen kennt außer Apple, glaube ich, keiner so richtig, weil sie die nie bekannt gegeben haben. Sondern die haben sie immer so in Desktops, in der Gesamtzahl untergehen lassen. Aber es gab ja neulich diese Antwort von einem Apple Repräsentativ. Ich weiß nicht, ob du das gelesen hast. Da war irgendwas über jemand, der halt auch so beklagt hat, oh Gott, die Welt geht unter, Steve Jobs hat keine Keynotes mehr und morgen ist der Mcmini flöten. Und naja, er kriegte so eine Antwort nach dem Motto, er solle doch etwas warten und alles wird gut. Und ja, das ist auch, glaube ich, meine Erwartungshaltung. Ich glaube, die Mcmini können sie nicht, oder wollen sie auch nicht vom Markt wegnehmen. Weil der einfach viele, viele, viele interessante Nischen füllt. Und zwar ist der Mcmini überhaupt der Nischenfüller schlechthin. Und zwar gar nicht mal eine bestimmte Nische, sondern eigentlich alle anderen. Weil der Mcmini, den kannst du nehmen als so ein billiges Media-Center. Mcmini ist so der ideale Einsteiger-Umsteiger-Computer, den du da zukaufst zu deinem schon existierenden USB-Tastatur-Bildschirm-Kombo, wenn du ein PC hast. Der Mcmini ist super für Künstler, die das in Installationen einbauen können, für Reisende, Audio-Musiker, die das sozusagen als Stage-Computer verwenden, und so weiter, und so weiter, und so weiter, und so weiter. Und das ist schon ein feines Teil. Und ich hab den ja jetzt hier auch irgendwie im Einsatz und würde mir noch besseres Frontroh wünschen dafür, so als Media-Center. Aber grundsätzlich ist das halt schon eine feine Sache. Und sie werden da Display-Port reinmachen. Ich frage mich nur, ob sie Firewire fallen lassen werden.
Vielleicht.
Vielleicht, das wär...
Aber um ihre Displays und ihren Standard ein bisschen anzukurbeln, könnte das schon sein, dass sie jetzt einen Mini-Display-Port rausbringen.
Das werden sie bestimmt machen. Also da bin ich mir eigentlich sicher, dass es kommt. Also der Mac Mini wird kommen. Und der wird sehr, sehr wahrscheinlich auf dieser Mac World vorgestellt werden. Phil Schiller wird zwei Stunden...
Ich find ja, so ein Mini ist auch immer so ein bisschen wie ein Apple TV. Also ein Apple TV ist halt kein richtiger Rechner und ein Mac Mini ist kein richtiges Apple TV. Also eigentlich müsstest du das mal ein bisschen zusammenfügen.
Aber ein Apple TV ist ja was ganz anderes. Wie du schon sagtest, das ist kein richtiger Rechner. Aber ein Mac Mini ist ein Rechner.
Könnte ja einer sein.
Ist doch ein OS X drauf oder nicht? Ja, aber ein OS X ist auch auf dem iPhone. Das ist eine Appliance. Und das heißt, es ist gebaut für einen bestimmten Zweck. Es hat ja auch Schnittstellen, die sonst kein Macintosh hat. Es gibt keinen Macintosh mit HDMI.
Es gibt nur Rätseln, weil wir wissen ja wirklich keine Verkaufszahlen von dem Ding. Also Apple könnte sagen, wir haben nur 10.000 verkauft oder von mir aus nur 100.000. Das ist ja alles total viel. Oder in deren Sicht wahrscheinlich total wenig. Und dann sagen sie, zack weg damit.
Na wissen tun wir nix, wir spekulieren. Das ist Glaskugelabteilung. Aber ich sag dir, es wird eine neue Version rauskommen, bald. Sie wird Mini DisplayPort haben. Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob sie noch Firewire haben wird. Ich hoffe ja. But I don't know. Es könnte auch sein, dass sie das genauso wie beim MacBook dem Preis opfern. Sozusagen einfachere Platine, dass sie da quasi einen MacBook reinbauen in den Mac Mini. Weil letzten Endes ist das... Ich bin mir nicht so sicher, welche Plattform-Ähnlichkeit das Ding hat. Mittlerweile ist es ja recht alt. Also zu aktuellen Geräten hat es auf jeden Fall keine Ähnlichkeit mehr. Aber es ist halt einfach so der billigste verfügbare Prozessor. Also sie sparen da einfach enorm an allem. Deswegen ist er halt auch so oll. Aber ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass sie halt jetzt mit der MacBook-Plattform da reingehen und sagen, ok, das Ding muss klein sein, das muss stromsparend sein, da ist ja nicht viel Platz drin in dem Teil. Das ist ja kleiner als ein Laptop. Das muss man ja auch mal sehen. Der ist aber auch kleiner als der nicht-Display-Teil eines Laptops. Also wenn du deinen Laptop in der Mitte durchschneidest und so Sandwich-mäßig so zusammenklappst auf Mac-Mini-Größe, dann ist der größer.
Ja klar, hat ja auch keine Batterie drin.
Ist aber auch eine Tastatur mit drin.
Puh, ich hab gar nicht mitbekommen.
Klar haben wir das mitbekommen.
Warten darauf, dass du gruselst.
Aber die hören nicht.
Achso, du hast ja auch nichts beizutragen gehabt. Wie sieht es denn aus an der Glühweinfront?
An der Glühweinfront sieht es aus, dass der jetzt natürlich erstmal warm werden muss.
Du hast so einen halben Schluck genommen.
Weil wir fangen schon wieder an relativ gradlinig zu argumentieren und straighte Analysen zu machen. Ich glaube, es könnte etwas mehr Ho Ho Ho und...
Was haltet ihr denn von einem Mac Mini Air? Ohne optisches Laufwerk?
Mac Mini Air?
Laufwerke können eh weg. Die soll man sich extra kaufen.
Laufwerke können noch nicht weg.
Doch, find schon.
Mac Mini wirst du in eine DVD reinschieben können. Wozu? Na, weil es ein Mediencenter ist.
Wir sagen ja im Club immer, weil wir haben dieser DVD-Player, der spinnt rum, der bleibt stehen, der überspringt Kapitel, der kommt mit den Subteilen jetzt nicht klar. Deswegen holen wir unseren Redaktions-Mac hoch und sagen, es ist der most sophisticated DVD-Player on Earth. Und da der in letzter Zeit kaputt gegangen ist, nehmen wir jetzt gerade ein aktuelles MacBook Pro. Also wirklich das ganz neue als DVD-Player. Es gibt nichts besseres.
Anstatt einfach mal ein Mac Mini zu kaufen?
Ja, wir haben ja da MacBook Pros und Zeug am Start. Und das mit denen funktioniert. Da stimmt der Gamma-Wert gleich. Da kommt digital Audio raus. Das ist alles prima mit dem Zeug.
Das geht.
Weil kauft man DVD-Player mit DVI-Ausgang. Zahlt sich dumm und dämlich, wenn du einen findest. Wenn überhaupt. Weil die haben alle nur so... Weiß ich gar nicht. Für Normalpreise kriegst du keinen. So DVD-Player kriegst du für 20 Euro. Ist kein Ding. Aber die haben halt hier nur, keine Ahnung, S-Video oder so ein Schnickschnack. Wenn du Glück hast, kriegst du welche mit VGA oder weiß ich nicht, aber so mit DVI. Da haben die ja gleich Angst. Da kommen ja die Daten digital raus. Da könnte man ja die DVD mit schneiden, als wenn es keinen Ripper geben würde. Und man sich das vom Anschluss abklaut. So ein Blödsinn.
Ich glaube, das Problem ist vielmehr, dass der Markt nicht da ist.
Der Markt ist nicht da. DVI ist einfach kein etablierter Konsumoutput.
Ja, verstehe ich ja nicht.
Und S-Video, ich meine, bessere Qualität kriegst du da auch kaum runter von der DVD.
Ja, ich finde schon.
Ein bisschen vielleicht, aber nichts, was jetzt dem Konsumenten einen großen Unterschied macht. Das wird immer noch alles über Skat angeschlossen. Macht immer keine Illusion. Und wenn da digital reinkommt, dann eben HDMI. Aber zum Apple TV, naja, da warte ich ja jetzt eigentlich nur noch drauf, dass sie auch wirklich...
Du wolltest ja auch einen von kaufen, oder?
Ich hab das mal erwogen. Ich hab jetzt auch mal versucht, auf Ebay mir mal einen günstig zu schießen. Jetzt wo ich so einen Fernseher habe, der auch so einen Y-UV-Eingang hat. Aber es ist nicht möglich, es ist nicht möglich, es ist nicht möglich, sowas günstig zu bekommen. Also so ein Apple TV, 40 GB, geht für 220 Euro weg derzeit auf Ebay. Und neu kosten die 299. Nee, vor allem kriegst du den irgendwie bei einem anderen Ebay-Anbieter sogar für 219 Euro neu. Das wär sozusagen auch nochmal so eine Option, aber ich weiß auch noch nicht, ob mir das sozusagen wirklich wert ist.
Na man kann ja noch nicht mal, doch ein bisschen, kann man hier schon shoppen, aber noch die Mieten geht das hier in Deutschland auch schon.
Genau, wenn man Filme, also wenn man wirklich einen Film-Rentalservice hätte, dann wär das......gut, ja. Wenn man wirklich auch so seinen Fernseher im Wesentlichen für sowas nutzt. Weil ich benutze meinen Fernseher zum Beispiel nicht, um damit Fernsehen zu gucken. Ich wollte nur ein großes Display haben und die billigste Möglichkeit, ein großes Display zu haben ist halt einen Fernseher zu kaufen. Da hat man das Problem, dass da halt auch noch zufällig ein Fernseher drin ist. Na gut, da kann man ab und zu mal Phönix einschalten oder so, aber der Rest ist ja nicht zu vertragen.
Also hast du ein Fernseher, um deinen Rechner anzuschließen, um deines TV-Shows?
Na so als Film- und Spielekonsole-Display ist das eigentlich gedacht. Solches wird es auch benutzt.
Und was hat dein neuer Fernseher alles für Eingänge?
Naja, also das Übliche. Die haben da halt immer noch so eine Batterie-Scart und dann halt irgendwie zwei, drei HDMI und Y-UV mindestens einmal.
Y-UV ist denn woher? Also wo hast du sowas auf der anderen Seite?
An meiner Nintendo Wii.
Ah, da kommt Y-UV raus.
Da kommt Y-UV raus. Also an Apple TV kommt sowas auch raus. Da kommt auch HDMI raus. Aber da könnte auch Y-UV angeschlossen werden. Verstehe, verstehe.
Weil es ist ja das Format, in dem die DVD und MPEG und sowas, was deren eigentliches Fab-Format ist.
Internes Encoding, sozusagen.
Das heißt, es muss dann nicht mehr nach RGB gewandelt werden, weil das geht nämlich nicht komplett verluzter, also schon, aber nicht ganz. Und dann kann man das direkt durchreichen.
Genau.
Ist auch ein Stück schneller.
Aber soweit ich das gesehen habe, haben die Fernseher heutzutage nicht so viele Eingänge davon. Einen haben sie alle, mehr oder weniger, oder viele zumindest, aber nicht mehrere. Es gibt wieder Glühwein. Haben wir das schon angesagt? Das ist die Weihnachtssendung von Mobile Macs.
Stimmt, das haben wir noch gar nicht gesagt.
Das soll euch einfach festlich stimmen. Was immer das heißen mag. Ich habe auch ein bisschen meinen Frieden gefunden jetzt mit Weihnachten, muss ich sagen. Ich mochte das ja früher immer nicht.
Jetzt wo du Familie hast?
Das hilft, auf jeden Fall. Aber auch ansonsten ist es irgendwie auch ein bisschen anstrengend, sich da mal gegenzuwehren.
Du hast dich gegen Weihnachten gewährt, inwiefern das denn?
Ich wohne ja in Berlin, weißt du?
Da bist du einfach irgendwo anders hingegangen.
Da geht man aus, da ist man dagegen.
Ist das nicht alles ein bisschen deprimierend, wenn dann alle nur weggehen, weil sie nicht alleine zu Hause rum sitzen wollen?
Was nochmal? Was ist deprimierend?
Weihnachten ist erst, wenn man folgenden Song hört.
Was kommt denn jetzt? Dennis möchte so einen eigenen Audiozugang haben hier in meinem Mixer.
Das ist erstaunlich. Obwohl du nicht trinkst bist von Betrunknissen.
Kannst du den Gedanken bitte...
Ich weiß nicht so, Weihnachten... Ich kenne nur die dreieinhalb Male. Ich war mal irgendwie am ersten Weihnachtsfeiertag dann so unterwegs. Das war alles schon ein bisschen gezwungen. Das machte so den Eindruck, dass da Leute so, hey, wir machen heute was ganz anderes als Weihnachten. Und am 24. Stelle ich mir das noch schlimmer vor.
Soll jeder so glücklich werden, wie er will. Ich hab hier auch in Berlin auf diesen ganzen... Ich meine, du kannst halt hier am 24. Dezember um 22 Uhr in den Club gehen und es ist voll.
Ja, okay, das kann man aber fundlich in jeder Stadt.
Nein.
Also ich hab gerade von einem Freund...
Also das kann man sicherlich... An manchen Orten in vielen Städten machen, aber bestimmt nicht in jeder Stadt, in jeder Bar.
Also gerade in kleinen Käfern soll es so sein, dass die Leute, die dann über Weihnachten alle nach Hause fahren und wenn dann die Alten um 22 Uhr besoffen sind, dann setzen sich die Jüngeren, die wieder zugereisten, alle ab in die Kneipe und treffen sich dann am 24. erstmal. So richtig alte Tradition. Und kenne ich wirklich von relativ vielen Leuten. Also insofern, ich glaube, das gibt es nicht nur in Berlin.
Naja, ich meinte jetzt explizit diese Gruppe von Nicht-Weihnachten. Diese komplett ignoranten, nicht ignoranten, sondern ich feier heute richtig. Ich kein Baum, ich keine rote Mütze.
Baum und rote Mütze bin ich bei dir.
Aber ich meine, das geht ja auch für Apple-Fans. Unser Weihnachten ist eh im Januar. Das ist ja schon fast jüdisch früher.
Was können wir eigentlich machen, um das wieder zurückzuholen?
Ich sag dir, Weihnachten ist jetzt einfach zwei bis drei Mal im Jahr. Es wird einfach mehr Weihnachten geben im Apple-Land. Wie ich schon geglaskugelt habe, denke ich mal, dass sie sich was einfallen lassen werden.
Ach so, stimmt ja.
Ich meine, die Show an sich ist natürlich wichtig. Aber mal ehrlich, wenn der in seiner kleinen Kapsel in Cupertino auf seinem eigenen Dings da sitzt mit 20 ausgewählten Pressevertretern, da wird einfach nicht so gejauchzt und gejubelt. Was auf jeden Fall bleiben wird, ist die Worldwide Developers-Konferenz. Die wird jetzt natürlich noch Tempel-Liga. Tempel-Liga.
Tempel-Liga, wie Tempel. Aber da stellen die ja nicht wirklich Produkte vor.
Das haben sie manchmal auch getan. Und das werden sie sicherlich auch dieses Mal, naja, weiß ich nicht, was sie zur WWDC machen. Das werden wir sehen. Auf jeden Fall, da sind auch schon mal Powerbooks vorgestellt worden. Obwohl sie es eigentlich nicht gemacht haben in letzter Zeit und das sicherlich auch sinnvoll ist, da es eine andere Audience ist. Aber ich könnte mir halt vorstellen, dass sie jetzt, was weiß ich, dass sie sich einfach in ein größeres Center mieten, wo eben genauso viele Leute reinpassen. Einfach nur dafür. Das haben sie auch schon ein paar Mal gemacht. Die letzten Veranstaltungen und Produktankündigungen waren immer an unterschiedlichen Orten, auch im Moskow-Center und so. Und da kriegen sie die ja auch zusammen. Aber die können sie halt besser auswählen.
Ich hab so ein bisschen das Gefühl, dass sie probieren, aus der Not eine Tugend zu machen. Also das mag sein, dass Steve Jobs jetzt nicht übermorgen sterben wird und auch nicht unbedingt jetzt wirklich den Krebs haben, den alle vermuten. Aber ich kann mir vorstellen, dass der irgendwann auch mal sagt, ich hab jetzt lang genug mir den Arsch aufgerissen.
Trassen? Trassen konnten sie ihn ja nicht als Kino-Sprecher angeben, weil, gibt's gar nicht.
Die Hologrammaschine ist einfach ausgefallen. Steve Jobs ist echt. Der ist nie zurückgekommen.
Es ist nicht so, dass es ihm schlecht geht, er ist eigentlich schon längst tot.
Genau. Dafür haben sie es ganz schön gut hingetreten.
Und in Wirklichkeit wird der Laden von Steve Wozniak geleitet.
Ich hoffe, der Tag wird nicht kommen.
Ich glaube auch. Ich glaube, die stellen sich schon ein bisschen darauf ein, dass es irgendwann mal einen Nachfolger brauchen wird. Und wenn sie keinen Nachfolger finden, dann werden sie wahrscheinlich einfach überhaupt nur die Keynoten zugucken.
Ich meine, alleine die News, dass er diese Keynote nicht mehr hält, hat dafür heute gesorgt, dass der Kurs um 8,75 Prozent eingebrochen ist. Das würde bei keiner anderen Firma so passieren, glaube ich.
Ja, aber die Börse hat eh eine Waffe.
Ihr das sowieso.
Ja, auf diese Waffe müssen sie hören. Ein bisschen auch. Obwohl, sie haben genug Bareserven, brauchen keine Kredite.
Ich sage euch, Phil wird das gut machen.
Ich setze voll auf Phil Schiller.
Wir müssen aber vorher noch ein bisschen abnehmen.
Und erinnert ihr euch noch an diese großartige Special Version von I'm a PC, I'm a Mac, die er auf der Worldwide Developers-Konferenz letztes Jahr gezeigt hat. Wo John Hodgman kommt als PC, aber verkleidet mit Jeans und schwarzem Shirt. Hello, I'm Steve Jobs. Und dann irgendwie, I'm shutting down Apple. Und dann nach einer Weile kommt dann der Mac. Und dann so, PC, not again. We talked about this. Und dann so, oh jam, ja, bestimmt, du hast recht. Hello, I'm Phil Schiller, sagt er dann. Das wäre dann im Prinzip genau schon die Voraussage gewesen, damals, was jetzt passiert ist.
Sie nehmen einfach Hodgman.
Das wäre auch cool. John Hodgman macht die Keynote. Wow, hervorragende Idee.
Und zwar aus PC Sicht. Ja, das ist schon ganz geil. Aber naja, nicht so richtig, aber diese Farben.
Ja, das wäre nicht schlecht.
Da gab es auch dieses Interview mit dem Wallstreet-Typen hier. Wie heißt der? Mit dem Wallstreet Journal und mit Bill Gates. Wie ist denn das? So eine Podiumsdiskussion auf so einer Veranstaltung. Das ist eine Wallsberg. Bill Gates meinte, dass der PC gar nicht so schlecht wäre. Und dann meinte Steve Jobs, das wäre der Trick an der Sache. Dass der eigentlich der nette Typ ist. Und der andere, den Mac, den Typen mag eigentlich gar keiner. Sondern Hodgman ist ja der Star von den beiden.
Das stimmt, das funktioniert super dadurch.
Genau, alle mögen ihn.
Ja, sonst würde man irgendwann Mitleid kriegen.
Ja, hast du ja eigentlich auch. Der ist voll nett, aber die arme Sauwister und so, hat ja eigentlich keine Chance. Gibt es übrigens zwei neue Spots, habt ihr gesehen jetzt, ne? Genau, und No und Lassma und so.
Schon gesehen, diese Weihnachtstinger.
Ach so, ja, doch, die sind sehr niedlich.
Deanimated.
So, da ist so ein bisschen Ausatmend. Ich glaube, wir müssen jetzt mal...
Stimmt, die animieren. Wolli macht einfach die Kinos in Zukunft.
Wir müssen jetzt mal strikt nach Liste vorgehen, glaube ich.
Strict nach Liste, genau. Was denn? Nicht so kalifornisch ableiern, sondern jetzt hier ordentlich in deutsche Struktur rein kriegen.
Und dann schumme ich mich gleich mal dazwischen, während du Liste liest. Und zwar fällt mir gerade ein, wer den Wolli-Film gesehen hat, der hat ja auch den Vorfilm gesehen, diesen Presto mit dem Hasen und dem Zauberer.
Der ist knuffig.
Voll lustig. Hast du den Wolli-Film gesehen? Ja, Presto, wo der Zauberer so in die Mütze greift und auf der anderen Seite durch so eine andere Mütze wieder rauskommt und dann den Hasen dann mal so durchzieht. Und der Hase, der knurrt voll der Bauch, weil er seine Morube noch nicht bekommen hat und spielt halt nicht mit und hat kein Bock mehr.
So eine Zauber-Show auf der Bühne.
Hast du Wolli nicht im Kino gesehen, gib's zu. Richtig. Du hast ihn runtergeladen ohne Vorfilm.
Den Vorfilm kriegt man noch im Netz.
So, den kriegt man im Netz. Gebe ich dir gleich.
Du hast noch nicht im Kino gesehen, oder?
Aber es gibt noch einen zweiten Film. Ich weiß nicht, ob der auf der DVD drauf war oder wo auch immer. Jedenfalls gibt's den auch in der Piratenbucht. Der heißt Burn-E, anstatt Woll-E. Der spielt parallel während der Wolli-Geschichte.
Burn-E.
Nee, Burn.
Burn, wie Brennen.
Genau. Weil eine Lampe fällt aus. Während Wolli so rumfliegt, geht ein Teil ab. Jedenfalls, so ein Komet oder wie auch. Muss sie angucken. Jedenfalls geht so eine Lampe außerhalb an dem Schiff kaputt. Und Bernie muss halt hingehen, die alte Lampe wegmachen und eine neue ran schweißen. Und weil dann halt Wolli schon wieder dran vorbeifliegt oder irgendwelche Abenteuer stattfinden, die halt im Film so vorkamen, kriegt er diese Lampe halt nicht repariert und muss immer eine neue holen. Und das Gerät, was Supply R heißt, gibt ihm halt immer eine neue und ist schon so ein bisschen wütend, weil er schon seine dritte Lampe verhaunert und so. Und dann, naja, ist also eine ganz witzige Geschichte. Wie schreibt sich das? Na, B-U-R-N-E.
Wie spricht sich das?
Ja, und der kommt so ein bisschen R2D2-mäßig natürlich auch rüber. Sein Gesicht ist so eine Schweißmaske, weil er muss ja immer schweißen.
Taucht der nicht auch in einem normalen Film auf?
Weiß ich nicht, ganz kurz vielleicht nur. Also die Geschichte spielt aber parallel zur echten Geschichte. Also die anderen Bilder so immer. Ja, ganz offiziell.
Cool, gibt's hier auch als 720p. 720p?
Weiß ich nicht, aber ich hab hier...
Ich steh grad auf 720p, wenn ich jetzt...
Weil du jetzt den Fernseher dafür hast.
Ich lag immer in so dick runter, wie ich halt kriege. So. Und Bernie habe ich hier den BD-Rip H264. Ich denk mal, weiß nicht, ob das Blu-ray ist. Jetzt sind wir schon wieder voll abgekommen. Ich wollte eigentlich ein bisschen nach Lista. Also das, was ich hier hab, ist 69 mal 400. 69 mal 400 ist meine Version groß.
Das ist doch jetzt egal. Du wolltest jetzt nach Lista gehen. Wir können ja unser Trading in aller Privathalt später durchführen. Ja, bitte. Ach so, Liste. Herr Professor. Naja, wir wurden auch schon hier in den Kommentaren befragt. Das ist vielleicht mal ganz angemessen. Dann müssen wir wahrscheinlich nochmal kurz auf das iPhone-Thema zurück. 25C3, Ausblick? Ausblick? Hinblick auf, also 25C3, der 25. Chaos Communication Congress, der jetzt in ein paar Tagen...
Am 27. 30.
Wo wir dann alle sein werden? Du auch, Max?
In Berlin Mitte.
Mindestens einen Tag auf jeden Fall.
Mindestens einen Tag auf jeden Fall. Dann wahrscheinlich den Tag, wo das iPhone-Dev Team da ist.
Das ist der zweite gleich, oder?
Gute Frage.
Die kommen auf jeden Fall.
Das heißt, die Jungs, die jetzt gerade auch angekündigt haben, dass sie einen Unlock haben?
Bis dann, wenn der zu Silvester rauskommen wird.
Das werden sie dann wahrscheinlich auf dem Kongress präsentieren, vermute ich mal.
Also Leute, nicht auf 2.2 updaten. Zumindest nicht auch die Firmware, sonst gibt der Unlock nicht mehr. Es gibt wohl von dem Dev-Team eine 2.2er Softwareversion, wo aber die neue Firmware einfach nicht mehr drin ist. Das heißt, das ist schon die neueste Software, aber noch mit der alten Firmware, dann geht es natürlich trotzdem. Aber wenn man die neueste Firmware hat, ist man raus.
Erster Tag, Saal 1, 20.30 Uhr. Hacking the iPhone, Poning, Apple's Mobile Internet Device, Muscle Nerd, Poitay und Planet Being. Englisch.
Pumpkin auch?
Vom Pumpkin steht hier nichts. Also mindestens drei Vertreter stehen auf der Bühne. Wie viele insgesamt vom iPhone-Dev-Team da sind, weiß ich nicht. Die sind ja auch schon längere Zeit so im CTC-Umfeld gesehen worden. Also die waren ja auch schon auf dem Camp.
Weiß ich gar nicht.
Ja, da hängen die schon rum. Da kannte sich noch keiner so richtig. Da fing das gerade erst an mit der Hackerei. Ja, und jetzt kommen sie auf den Kongress, machen Vortrag. 27. Wir sind alle da. Und... Max wohl auch.
Alle und ich.
Ja, ansonsten jetzt Kongress-Überblick, will ich sagen, ist hier nicht so ganz das Vorum.
Ja, da gibt es ja die entsprechenden Webseiten. www.cccd.de/kongressnehmeich mal an, oder?
Genau.
Und da steht dann der Rest, Eintrittspreise, Anfahrt, Übernachtungsmöglichkeiten und das Programm natürlich.
Genau. Da gibt es auch eine Menge zu gucken, wie immer. Kongress überhaupt, wer noch nicht da war, kann man sehr empfehlen. Tolle Veranstaltung, schräge Leute und eine Menge Macintoshes.
Beim letzten Mal mehr als Macs, gleich viel oder wie war das?
Beim letzten Mal war das glaube ich schon ein Drittel.
War es nicht 50-50?
Nee, nee. Aber ein Drittel aller Geräte, die auf dem Netz gesehen wurden, waren Macs. Tendenz steigend. Seit Jahren. Das ist viel.
Macs oder Apple-Geräte? Ich meine, dürften dieses Jahr dann eher...
Na ja, keine Ahnung. Ob letztes Mal schon iPhones gezählt wurden?
Müsste eigentlich.
Keine Ahnung, wie die Mac-Adressen ausgebildet wurden.
Vor einem Jahr war das ja noch nicht so cool mit den iPhones, weil, weiß ich auch noch nicht. So richtig viele gab es noch nicht.
Na, da wird es ein paar gegeben haben, aber ich glaube, das macht bei der Masse an Rechnern nicht so viel aus.
Also auf der Republikar...
Das könnte schon dieses Jahr anders sein....
waren ja mehr Geräte im WLAN eingebucht, als Besucher da waren.
Na klar, jeder an Rechner und Mac, ein iPhone mein ich.
Na ja, aber es waren auch ein paar Leute da, die hatten keinen Rechner dabei. Sehr, sehr wenig zugegebenermaßen.
Es gibt Leute, wo Leute zwei iPhones haben.
Beim Kongress war das schon vor zehn Jahren so, dass wir so eine Quote hatten von 1,1 Computer pro Teil.
Ja, das gibt es ja wirklich kaum Leute, die ohne Rechner kommen, oder?
Damals haben die auch noch ein bisschen mehr gewogen, das waren dann immer die Leute mit dem Muskelkater, oder?
Ja, das waren Zeiten, wo die alle noch mit ihrem Desktop ankamen.
Also es gibt da einfach viel Gier. Okay, next. Ja, dann wollte ich dich nochmal fragen, aber du hast ja schon so ein bisschen mit den Armen gewunken. Gewunken, du Dennis, du links Dennis, du, ähm, U-Torrent.
Ja, hab ich mir nicht weiter angeschaut. Ich weiß nur, dass jetzt die offizielle Version draußen ist. Also U-Torrent ist was?
U-Torrent ist dieses, das hat mal jemand, also BitTorrent kleint.
Das ist der Micro-Torrent von BitTorrent Org gekauft. Vorher war es eine freie Version und die haben gemerkt, mit ihrer Python-Version kommen sie dann nicht so wirklich weit und haben den Laden oder das Programm, die Software, wie auch immer, einfach mal aufgekauft und weiterentwickelt. Und da gibt es jetzt seit ein paar Wochen eine Beta-Version für einen Mac. Vorher gab es nur so einen Alpha, die irgendwie geleakt ist, jetzt gibt es offiziell. Dann haben sie noch mal eine Version nachgeschoben, 0.9.0.1 oder 0.9.1, weil sie irgendwie einen Minibug hatten, den sie schnell mal fixen mussten. Und sonst speziell für einen Mac gibt es da nicht Neues. Ich habe es einmal benutzt, hat funktioniert, mehr kann ich da gar nicht sagen. Ich weiß nur, dass sie ja noch dieses, wie nannten sie es jetzt, das UDP, also Micro-UDP oder sowas haben, wie haben die es genau genannt? Du hast das doch mal gepostet. Ich weiß nicht, wie die Abkürzung genau war.
Die Abkürzung weiß ich jetzt auch nicht. Aber was sie halt machen, ist, dass wenn sie untereinander verbunden sind, also wenn ein Microtorrent mit einem Microtorrent-Peer verbunden ist, dass sie dann halt nicht mehr TCP miteinander sprechen, sondern UDP.
Genau. Ich mache hier mit einem Freund diesen Open-Tracker zusammen mit dem Erdgeist. Und der meinte, wäre ja voll genial, weil halt die sowieso nur so einzelne abgeschlossene Pakete übermitteln und da braucht man keine dauerhafte Verbindung, die noch irgendwie halt die Menge regelt und das, was du bei TCP alles an Service noch so mitkriegst, das wäre in UDP alles besser und das könnten die dann selber machen. Ich weiß noch nicht, ob ich dem so zustimmen soll, weil du musstest dann halt auch alles selber machen und ich meine, wenn ich mir angucke, was für Idioten da draußen, also unter anderem halt Torrent-Client schreiben, das ist ja schon so ein bisschen zähn und jeder meint es irgendwie selber und besser machen zu können, da kommt dann auch eine Menge Müll bei raus und dann bin ich mir nicht so sicher, ob die das genauso gut hinkriegen, wie TCP was seit Jahren halt irgendwie, wo da die Leute ordentliche Software schreiben. Also ist natürlich auch nicht alles ordentlich, aber es ist halt abgehangen.
Ich sehe da nicht so viele Probleme, muss ich sagen. Ich meine, da ist eh intern schon ein Paket basiert.
Ich bin noch nicht fertig. Weil wenn man nämlich das schon neu macht, wenn ich es irgendwie richtig gesehen habe, ich hab's mir noch nicht ganz genau angekündigt, das Protokoll, aber es gibt neben UDP und TCP gibt es nämlich noch ein weiteres Protokoll, was seit Jahren irgendwie so ein bisschen eingeführt wird. Das nennt sich SCTP und das ist auch so ein Art Streaming-Protokoll, so eine Mischung zwischen TCP und UDP und das wär das eigentlich gewesen, was man genau für so was nehmen sollte.
Warum?
Na, weil man damit schön streamen kann. Du kannst ja entscheiden, ob du halt irgendwie, ob es halt eine bestehende Connection sein soll oder nicht. Also du bist da viel variabler und kannst da viel besser bestimmen, wie das abläuft. Wie sagt das in Zwischending zwischen UDP und TCP? Ich hab's mir noch nicht ganz perfekt angeguckt, aber ich denke mal, das wäre das Richtige gewesen, was die gerade von selbst implementieren, ist in SCTP schon alles mit drin. Und da hast du dann auch gleich halt den Support und richtig Leute, die auf den ersten Linux, FreeBSD und so weiter, die sich das angucken, das ist halt auch ein Standard.
Aber es ist ja kein Datenstrom. Ich meine, die Übertragung von Datenpaketen in BitTorrent, das hat ja nicht den Charakter eines Stroms, sondern es hat ja den Charakter von einzelnen Blöcken, die klar an bestimmte Orte zugeordnet sind und die nicht in einer bestimmten Reihenfolge übertragen werden müssen. So ein Stream-Control brauchst du halt wirklich nur dann, wenn die Reihenfolge eine Rolle spielt.
Was heißt denn Reihenfolge? Egal, welche Pakete da geschickt haben, für den Stream sind es halt Pakete, die da kommen.
Wenn wir unseren Radio-Stream hier irgendwie so schicken würden, das wäre egal, in welcher Reihenfolge die Pakete kommen, dann käme da nur Audiomüll bei raus. Das ist das, was ich meine. Die Reihenfolge. Plus bei dem Übertragen von Daten, wo an den Daten ja genau dran steht, um welche Daten es sich handelt und wo sie in dieser Datei sind. Und das bei UDP, also bei BitTorrent ja sowieso alles durcheinander ist, spielt sozusagen für die Übertragung vom Pier zum anderen Pier die Reihenfolge, in der die Pakete ankommen, keine Rolle. Und deswegen denke ich, dass da UDP ganz genau so funktionieren wird. Da brauchst du kein STP.
Aber dann muss der mit UDP wieder die Pakete zusammenklatschen, bis er wieder seine 16 Kilo-Bytes hat. Das muss er irgendwie dem anderen übermitteln, wenn was nicht geklappt hat.
Das Ganze ist nur in TCP eingehüllt.
Ja, immer, das ist doch voll gut. Da wird ja doch Arbeit abgenommen.
Nein, da wird ja gar keine Arbeit abgenommen, weil letzten Endes das, was das TCP drumherum macht, nämlich Sliding Windows und die Reihenfolge erhalten und sicherstellen, dass wirklich etwas auch angekommen ist.
Und erneut mal fragen, wenn was nicht angekommen ist.
Ja, aber das ist komplett void, weil du bei BitTorrent ist das sowieso ein Grundprinzip des Protokolls, dass Sachen, die noch nicht da sind, wieder neu angefragt werden. Das findet eh statt und die Reihenfolge ist egal und Sliding Windows ist nur störend für die Performance. Also meiner Meinung nach ist das von Anfang an eine schlechte Entscheidung gewesen und mag eher was damit zu tun haben, wie du Peer-to-Peer-Connections, wie du sozusagen durch die Router durchkommst. Weil bei UDP verhältten sich die Router anders und bei TCP sind diese Probleme mit Port-Forwarding erst mal schneller gelöst gewesen als bei UDP. Naja, wir müssen das mal genauer anschauen und dann können wir uns das nochmal angucken. Ich dachte, du hättest da schon tiefer reingeschaut, aber auf jeden Fall gibt es das.
Ich weiß noch nicht, ob das in der Mac-Tosh-Version schon drin ist. Die PC-Version hat das aber schon.
Na gut, das wird sicherlich noch nachkommen. Achso, okay, ich dachte, die werden sowieso auf allen Plattformen gleich.
Da weiß ich halt eben nicht.
Es gibt ja bisher erst eine 2. Plattform, wenn ich das richtig mitbekommen habe, oder? Also die Mac-Plattform ist doch die 2. für... Microtorrent. Ich hätte es jetzt Mytorrent oder sowas genannt.
Mühlmicro, was auch immer. Na gut, mir gehen die Themen jetzt auch so ein bisschen aus.
Die Liste ist schon vorbei, ich dachte, da wäre noch voll viel Zeug.
Na, ich hab hier so Kleinkram noch. Also ich hab mir noch gemerkt, dass Google Earth jetzt auch als Safari-Plugin zur Verfügung steht. Ich hab's auch installiert, aber ich hab's ehrlich gesagt kaum benutzt. Weil es ist so Bahnbrechendurch auch nicht. Dann wurde noch eine Vermutung von mir so ein wenig bestätigt, finde ich zumindest, die ich hier mal geäußert habe, nämlich was sozusagen den Zusammenhang zwischen OpenCL und CUDA von Nvidia betrifft. Nun ist das ja mit dem OpenCL sehr fix gegangen, weil ich das letzte Mal auch schon darüber geredet. Und Nvidia ist mal ein bisschen öffentlicher geworden und hat das alles kommentiert. Jetzt wo OpenCL abgeschlossen ist und meinten so, ja, OpenCL wäre letzten Endes nicht sehr viel mehr als so eine Abstraktion, die auf ihre CUDA mehr oder weniger seamless aufsetzt. Also CUDA ist sozusagen ihre Computing-Plattform für ihre Chips. Wie macht man generische Berechnungen, wie lässt man quasi Programmcode ablaufen, dass Berechnungen durchführt auf Grafikkarten mit dieser hohen Parallelisierung.
AMD hat ja sowas auch, richtig? Also nicht AMD, sondern ATI.
ATI hat sowas auch, da heißt das Streams oder so.
Ja, da hat wahrscheinlich Apple gesagt, hört mal zu, ist ja ganz geil und wir wollen es auch fett nutzen und so. Und es ist ja auch gut für euch, wenn wir eure Grafikkarten gut nutzen, weil dann wollen die Leute auch schnellere Grafikkarten haben, weil machen ja nicht alle nur so Power-3D-Grafik hier irgendwie zum Zocken, sondern auch andere Sachen. Aber wir wollen nicht irgendwie Streams und irgendwie CUDA unterstützen, ihr müsst das mal unter einen Hut bringen. Und hat die alle mal unter dieser Chronos-Gruppe da zusammengeholt und die haben auch alle mitgemacht. Also da ist ja sowohl ATI als auch NVIDIA mit am Tisch gekommen.
Genau.
Und Intel auch eigentlich?
Ich weiß nicht, wer da alles mit drin ist, aber im Prinzip sind sich alle einig. Ich glaube, die einzigen, die da nicht mitspielen, ist Microsoft.
Weil die einen DirectX-Gramm haben und da erstmal ein bisschen hinterher sind, ne?
Genau. Und ja, jetzt muss man halt sehen, was die Implementierung von Apple ins No-Leapboard da wirklich bringt. Aber ich vermute mal, dadurch, dass sozusagen die Abstraktionen dieselbe sind, das ist jetzt nicht noch mal so ein gigantischer Layer da drüber, sondern das ist wirklich, also so wie OpenGL damals wirklich von den Realitäten der Grafikkarten ausgegangen ist und deswegen so ein gutes Interface war.
Da gab's ja...
Weil das halt kein Overhead gemacht hat und eben wirklich...
Da gab's ja irgendwo so ein Artikel, wo stand, dass OpenGL eigentlich schon so ein bisschen mal absterben war. Weil auch Microsoft hat mal wieder nicht mitgespielt, die haben ja ein DirectX-Zeugs halt gepusht und mit SGI ging's ja langsam so bergab und weil die waren ja, sind ja die Entwickler von OpenGL, ne? Und dann ging's irgendwie mit OpenGL bergab, weil es keiner mehr genutzt hat. Und dann hat Apple ja gesagt, hier, wir machen OpenGL als Grafik-Appi. Und dann ging's wieder so ein bisschen bergauf, auch bei halt Linux und so und die ganzen 3D-Spiele. Und wohl auch alle Konsolen außer Xbox nutzen wohl auch OpenGL. Sonst wär das Ding nämlich schon tot.
Und jetzt muss man halt sehen, also das mit dem OpenCL ist natürlich auch eine schöne, ist gerade bei dieser Chronos Group gut angesiedelt, weil jetzt gibt es halt mit OpenAL, also diesem Audio-Player.
Ist das auch bei denen?
Ja.
CL und GL gibt's sozusagen so ein komplettes Set von ich nutze, ich hab einmal diese, also OpenAL ist ja sozusagen 3D-Audio. Und OpenCL ist eben jetzt für, ich nutze die Grafik-Hardware für generisches Computing und eben OpenGL für die Grafik nach wie vor. Und das ist halt ein attraktives Paket. Und es wird ja in zunehmendem Maße genutzt. Es läuft halt auch auf dem iPhone. Also ich denke, das wird auch weiterhin der starke Standard bleiben. Und wie es um die Zukunft von DirectX bestellt ist, hängt im Wesentlichen eigentlich von der Zukunft von Windows ab.
Na, da war wohl das Problem mit diesem DirectX 10, was ja ziemlich heftig ist, dachten sie, sie können das pushen, indem halt auch die Spiele unter Vista alle DirectX 10 benutzen. Und dann ist das halt der Standard gut gepusht. Das ging aber in die Hose, weil halt niemand Vista hat. Deswegen die Spiele dafür nicht rauskamen und deswegen DirectX die entsprechende Unterstützung nicht bekommen hat, deswegen trampeln die auch schon seit einer Weile auf der Stelle. Deswegen gibt es ja auch kein neues DirectX, sondern es ist jetzt erstmal ein 10.1. Also die müssen wir immer langsam machen, weil die gar nicht hinterherkommen mit den ganzen Standards und der Unterstützung davon.
Microsoft ist schwer doomed, also ich wiederhole mich. Zu Weihnachten. Aber es ist, ja, ich meine, sie haben eigentlich alle ihre Ziele nicht erreicht derzeit.
Ja, wie so wirst du, Windows 7 kommt doch, die machen alles platt. Und bestimmt kommt auch noch WinFS, bevor ZFS und auch Mac erscheint.
Die Frage ist, wann, ja, und auch hier Windows Mobile 7 kommt höchstens in einem Jahr. So, und sogar die letzten Companies, die noch zu ihnen gehalten haben, wechseln mittlerweile die Lager, beziehungsweise treten zumindest an der Lager bei. Also Sony Ericsson, die ja auch Windows-Mobile-Geräte rausgebracht haben, obwohl sie ja auch schon Jahre lang Symbian einsetzen.
Na ja, aber so richtig, die haben genau eins jetzt rausgebracht, oder? Nie mehr. Oder die wollen jetzt ein Windows-Mobile-Gerät raus?
Ich weiß auch nur von einem.
Dieses Experience, oder wie das heißt.
Genau, die haben halt überall so ein bisschen mitgefeiert, aber die sind jetzt eben auch der Open-Handset-Alliance. Beigetreten.
Und da wird es bestimmt passen schicke Telefone geben.
Wir werden es sehen, auf jeden Fall kann man nicht davon reden, dass besonders viele Leute derzeit auf Windows setzen, sowohl im Mobilbereich als auch im PC-Bereich.
Also im PC-Bereich, glaube ich, hängt es ein bisschen davon ab, wie man fragt.
Es hängt davon ab, wie man fragt.
Wenn man sich in der Weltbevölkerung fragt, dann sagen die wahrscheinlich...
Ja, ich meine, drauf setzen heißt...
Verstehst du, was ich meine?
So dieses... hat es... Und ich meine, das, was Dennis sagt, das findet man ja... Also die sind einfach mit Vista in so eine ganz eklige Teerfalle rein gestoßen. Sie haben alles darauf gesetzt, dass sie eigentlich diese Durchmarschfähigkeit haben. Also ihre ganze Strategie zielte darauf ab, dass sie Vista automatisch überall auf jeden Desktop kriegt.
Das waren die halt so gewohnt.
Das ist nur eine Frage der Zeit.
Das waren die so gewohnt.
Das waren die so gewohnt. Ich kann mich noch erinnern, ich habe hier vor zwei Jahren auch so ein etwas heftigeres Küchengespräch mit einem Freund geführt, der jetzt auch kein Windows-Vertreter ist, aber sich meiner Apple-Affinität nicht gerne anschließt. Was bedürfen hat sich dem zu widersetzen? Ich habe ihm halt gesagt, dass Microsoft diesmal so nicht gelingen würde. Das war halt das klassische Argument. Die sind so groß, die sind überall, die haben 90 Prozent, die werden einfach installiert, die werden einfach verkauft. Was haben wir jetzt erlebt? Wir haben erlebt, dass so was wie ein Downgrade-Kit der totale Renner wird.
Aber jetzt mal ganz unter uns...
Und wenn du es bei Dell'n XP haben willst, kostet es schon 150 Euro. So?
Scheiße?
Nein, so langsam. Du brauchst so einen fetten Rechner dafür.
Die Anforderungen sind einfach zu hoch und die Kompatibilitäten mit der Hardware waren am Anfang ein großes Problem. Und jetzt ist halt das Image in der Tonne, selbst wenn ihre Service Packs die eigentlichen Probleme, die bekleidet wurden, so. Das andere Ding ist, dass in der Business-Welt keiner upgradet. Also keiner im Sinne von keiner nennenswerte Zahl. Und das ist so.
Ja, aber ich meine, mit der Business-Welt, wie lange, wie viele Jahrzehnte wurde da mit NT4 gearbeitet, als als Minus 2000 schon lange Stand der Dinge war und...
Und mit XP geht es halt auch so. Bloß das Ding ist, die können halt jetzt einfach wichtige Technologieschritte nicht mehr vornehmen.
Sie haben jetzt erstmal ein versautes Image und das müssen sie jetzt erstmal wieder...
Und Apple hat es ja prima nachgelegt. Die haben gesagt, unser Snow Leopard, wir machen den nur stable. Wir machen eine neue Feature. Aber ist ja so, da hauen die nochmal voll einen oben drauf.
Und das wirkt.
Und wir bauen Exchange ein.
Ich glaube, die Strategie von Microsoft basiert darauf, dass so weiterhin Steve Jobs immer ein bisschen Blei in sein Trinkwasser kippen.
Deswegen ist er so krank.
Ich unterschreibe das nicht.
Du meinst, du ziehst dich der Behauptung, dass Microsoft Konkurrenten töten würde? Ja. Ja, ich unterschreibe das jetzt auch eher science-fiction-mäßig. Um jetzt vom Thema abzurengen, was ich noch gefunden habe, ist das Weihnachtsgeschenk für jemanden, der schon alles hat. Klingeltöne für professionelle Klingeltöne für 9,95 Dollar gab es bei Tuha, wurden die bewertet. Die klingen sehr schick. Ich bin ernsthaft am Überlegen, ob ich mir nicht so dämliche Klingeltöne kaufen soll. Die klingen dann zum Beispiel so. Das ist jetzt eins fürs Meeting. Passiert gar nichts, wieso passiert denn hier nichts? Ach Scheiße.
Dafür würde ich jetzt keine 10 Dollar zahlen.
Aber ich meine, guck mal, ihr habt den Klingelton gar nicht gehört.
Wie sie hören, hören sie nichts.
Ja und, also nicht hörbaren Klingeltonen das ist mir auch 10 Dollar wert. gibt's billiger.
Genau, kann ich eigentlich einen White-Klingelton machen und bestimmte User drauflegen?
Was versuchst du eigentlich gerade zu tun?
Ich probier hier gerade. Achso, ich müsste vielleicht einen Ton abschalten, das würde dann viel mehr Sinn machen. Zum einen das, mal gucken. Das ist zum Beispiel einer von diesen Klingeltonen.
10 Dollar?
Das sind insgesamt 21 Stück. Noch einer.
14 Dollar oder pro?
Äh, insgesamt. So war's dann.
10 Dollar für ein so ein Ding?
Nee, für alle. Ich sag ja, für jemanden, der schon alles hat. Unter anderem Geld.
Das sind dann nur noch 50 Cent. Pro Ton. Hammer!
Total, oder?
Amazing!
Die Webseite ist aber echt hübsch gemacht. Findest du?
Das ist nur schwarz. Ich muss mir Silas dann schuldigen. Aber was mich stört, das ist beim iPhone, dass man einen bestimmten User nicht auf nicht klingeln legen kann. Das geht nicht, ne?
Nee, das geht nicht. Kann man überhaupt eigene Klingeltöne ausbringen pro User?
Man kann ja noch nicht mal einstellen, dass der Klingelton eine konstante Lautstärke hat. Oder lauter wird. Das wäre auch mal ganz schön nach einer Weile.
Ach so, hier so Ascending, wie beim Nokia. Das war eigentlich immer ganz schick. Ich hab immer das Ge-Tschirpe gemacht und dann Ascending. Oh Nokia, wie toll war's damals mit dir. Aber jetzt hier wegen der Weihnachts-Song vorhin, da gab's tatsächlich Werbung von Nokia, dass man halt diesen VAM-Sound, also diesen Song Last Christmas, irgendwie ja jetzt auf seinem Telefon hören könnte. Das heißt, die werben tatsächlich mit diesem 24 Jahre alten Christmas-Sound.
24 Jahre alt ist der?
Ja, 84.
Echt?
Na, VAM halt.
Jaja, ich weiß, du hast es schon mal angespielt.
Das kommt gleich nach Rick SW., oder?
Eigentlich.
Also da könnte man Leute genauso mit chocken, muss man im Sommer spielen, ist bestimmt voll fies.
Man Rick Rollt nicht mehr, man VAMmt?
Ja. Aber ich hab noch eine Sache, weil wir bei Microsoft waren, wir wollen ja nicht nur lästern, wir machen ja auch tolle Sachen. Zum Beispiel jetzt ein iPhone-Programm gibt es von Microsoft, wo sie halt ihre, wie heißt diese Plattform, wo man so ein Bild reinzoomen kann. Genau, das gibt es jetzt als, als, als, als, ach ich lese die News nicht.
Also ich meine, das ist Microsoft ein iPhone-Programm.
Er hat es doch hier, der Max hat es, ich lese, er hat es. So geht das. Wir machen hier Teamwork.
Ja, ich fand das Statement schön von Microsoft, dass sie meinten, das wäre die erste mobile Plattform, auf der dieses Software überhaupt eine Chance hat.
Ja, weil halt OpenGL auf dem iPhone ist und die entsprechende Hardware dazu. Sonst würde das halt nicht so gehen.
Also es ist ein Programm zum Betrachten von Gigapixel-Bildern.
Genau. Wahrscheinlich wollten sie halt ihre Technik mal näherbringen und wie kann es das halt den Leuten besser irgendwie unterjubeln, als dass sie einfach schnell mal ein iPhone-Programm holen.
Das geht wirklich schnell. Ich hab jetzt hier sogar so eine Weltkarte und ich zoom jetzt auf Berlin rein.
Die kommt aber jetzt über online rein, weil du hast ja nicht an der kompletten Größe da. Oder das wird alles nachgeladen?
Nee, ich hab da nicht die ganzen 48 GB, die dieses Bild groß ist. Das wird jetzt nach und nach eingeladen. Jetzt sehen wir hier...
Also eigentlich ist es so wie Google Earth.
In dem Fall schon, aber die haben ja noch ein paar andere Sachen.
Nur auch mit anderen Bildern halt.
Das heißt, es ist einfach nur ein dynamischer Zoom in bildliebige...
Und das ist auch schnell. Genau. Die haben ja zum Beispiel irgendwie...
Gibt's da irgendwie so Makro-Bilder von der Ameise oder irgendwie sowas?
Also wie Google Earth sozusagen.
Ja, aber die haben zum Beispiel so ein Bild, da sieht man irgendwie alle Flaschen, die gerade jetzt in den nächsten fünf Minuten in Amerika verbraucht werden, also ein bisschen so. Auch zum Nachdenken. Da ist die Bildhörschrift, die kann man da lesen, was steht da drunter?
Sobald das...
Das sind zwei Millionen Plastikflaschen.
1,2 Gigapixel.
Und das sind 1,2 Gigapixel. Und dann sieht man hier... Genau. Also 1,2 Gigapixel.
2 Millionen Plastikflaschen in 5 Minuten? Werden in den USA benutzt?
Offensichtlich. Wie viele Minuten hat Angis und Tal?
Das ist aber krass.
Eine Menge.
1.440. Aber...
2 Millionen in 5 Minuten?
24 mal 12, mal 12 mal eine Stunde. 24 wäre der ganze Tag, d.h. 288 mal wie viele Flaschen? 2 Millionen. Das wären 576 Millionen Flaschen am Tag.
Das hier sind pro Amerikaner fast zwei.
Na ja, haut doch hin oder nicht? Die trinken morgens halt irgendwie ihr Wasser und dann unterwegs nochmal.
Auf jeden Fall kann man da jetzt so reinzoomen.
Ja, schön unscharf.
Er lädt noch.
Er lädt ja noch.
Ich denke, das geht sau schnell.
Das geht sau schnell, wenn man nicht gerade LSD, das er hat.
Genau.
Schöner Seitenhieb.
Und jetzt kann man das Label auf der Flasche legen.
Also das ist sozusagen Google Earth für Fotos.
Und das ist schon eine geile Sache.
Aber Jungs, das ging ja auch gar nicht um die Technik an sich, sondern darum, dass Microsoft ein Programm eigentlich für die Findnes-Plattform rausbringt. Für die, wie sagt man, Konkurrenzplattform.
Aber was ist denn bitte da jetzt überhaupt das Besondere da dran?
Na du könntest halt mit so einem Device kein 1,2 Gigapixel-Foto einladen.
Na gut, aber ich meine, dieses Zooming...
Du brauchst relativ wenig...
Das ist ja nicht nur ein Zooming. Du kannst halt nicht das ganze Bild reinholen und dann nur eine Stelle anzeigen, sondern du musst halt das schon in klein reinholen.
Ja gut, aber das ist dasselbe, was Google Earth macht.
Also es gibt...
Plus nur mit Fotos.
Also das Streaming funktioniert auch von relativ harmlosen Rechnern aus. Also nicht nur der Client kann relativ klein sein, sondern auch der Server dafür kann relativ klein sein.
Ach, die Software liefern sie auch?
Ich weiß nicht, ob sie die ausliefern. Das haben sie irgendwann mal in so einem TED-Video ausführlich vorgestellt. Und da war es sehr beeindruckend. Aber ich weiß jetzt ehrlich gesagt auch gar nicht mehr warum. Vielleicht liegt es am Glühwein. Ich sollte mal ein bisschen tiefer an den Glühwein gehen.
Aber ich finde es schon nicht so unschlecht, dass es so eine Entwicklung in diese Richtung gibt. Weil wenn man sich jetzt antwortet, wo sind die Kameras jetzt, so diese, sagen wir mal, so Amateur-Kameras, oder wie heißt das? Profi-Kameras, 12 Megapixel oder 15 oder wo sind die inzwischen? Also in ein paar Jahren sind die irgendwie auch locker bei 50 oder 100 Megapixel.
Da bin ich ja mal gespannt drauf.
Und dann, warum sollte man sich noch mit so kleinen Bildern hier rum ärgern? Dann kriegt man so einen kleinen Ausschnitt und dann sagst du, das ist aber interessant, will ich ein bisschen mehr von wissen? Und dann kannst du halt da reinzoomen und irgendwo muss diese Technik herkommen und der Standard und so weiter. Man muss ja früh Standard setzen, das ist ja gerade Microsofts Ding.
Ich glaube, die fanden das einfach toll. Also gerade Microsoft Labs, die neigen ja dazu tolle Sachen zu entwickeln, die dann aber nie den Markt reifer schaffen.
Doch, aufs iPhone haben sie es geschafft.
Wollen wir ein Ende finden, Jungs?
Wieso sind die Süßigkeiten ausgegangen? Tatsächlich keine Domino Steine mehr. Dein Ding hast du auch nicht gegessen?
Und wir haben auch massenhaft Spekulatius.
Ja, wir haben Spekulatius. Wir haben auch noch ein bisschen Dürrwahl zu verzögern. Das machen wir auch noch, aber wir müssen ja jetzt nicht unbedingt, bis wir alles aufgegessen haben, hier senden. Nö, ich denke jetzt für so eine newsarme Weihnachtssendung haben wir glaube ich alles ganz gut zusammengepackt. Oder hat der Chat noch irgendwelche tollen Hinweise?
SimCity fürs iPhone.
Ja, hier werden noch alte News nochmal abgekraspert.
SimCity fürs iPhone gibt es gerade seit acht Minuten, oder?
Ach so, wir sollten ja noch iPhone-Applikationen vorstellen. Das haben wir schon zweimal versucht. Das ist jedes Mal ein totales Desaster bei uns.
Das haben wir doch.
Was? Na ja, vielleicht gibt es ja neue.
Ach na ja, SimCity, was? Das müssen die Leute selber herausfinden.
Nein, etwas, wovon wir benutzen, wovon wir überzeugt sind. Darum geht es doch.
Ich bin aus Schasam.
Das ist aber jetzt nicht neu. Wo benutzt du das denn?
Zum Musikerkennen. Wenn ich irgendwo bin und höre einen coolen Song, dann tschick, dann weiß ich, was es ist.
Kaufst du es dann auch gleich?
Ich gucke in meiner großen Sammlung nach, ob ich es nicht eh schon.
Habe. Ich habe Warnungen missachtet. Ich bin ja so ein Freund von so... Es gibt diesen Begriff Puzzle-Spiele, den ich ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen verwirrend finde, weil unter Puzzle stelle ich mir was anderes vor. Aber Bejeweled ist definitiv das Spiel, was ich noch am meisten spiele. Bejeweled 2 heißt es ja auf dem iPhone. Und es gibt dann noch so was Ähnliches, was einen auch ganz schön viel Zeit kostet. Und zwar ist das von diesem Craig Hockenberry, den wir schon erwähnt haben, der also auch Twitterifik gemacht hat. Das heißt Frenzik.
Das habe ich irgendwann mal auf dem Desktop gespielt, oder? Das ist auch schon relativ alt.
Das ist so ein Tortenstückchen. Das macht einen auf jeden Fall auch ganz schön irre.
Und du hast die Warnung ignoriert, dich das nicht zu kaufen, oder wie?
Ja, ich fand das eine interessante Beschreibung.
Aber stemmen das nicht das Fondlehr?
Ich muss sagen, ich weiß ja nicht, woran das liegt.
Da fährt man ein Ladegerät.
Also als ich das iPhone neu hatte, das kann jetzt damit zu tun haben, dass als ich es neu hatte, dass ich es wirklich wie ein Berserker die ganze Zeit benutzt habe. Bestimmt. Aber dann irgendwie, es gibt Tage, da sitze ich irgendwie auch rum und spiele die ganze Zeit, weil ich gerade irgendwie mich einfach ein bisschen entspannen will. Oder surf oder mach irgendwas die ganze Zeit. Aber ich habe den Eindruck, seitdem dieses 2.2 drauf ist, ist irgendwie echt alles besser. Also 2.1 hat definitiv schon eine Menge gebracht, aber das 2.2 hat auch eine Menge gebracht.
Dennis zeigt mir gerade ganz stolz, dass sein Telefon jetzt halb voll noch ist, obwohl es schon seit wieviel? Drei Tagen?
Drei Tage und zwanzig Stunden läuft.
Ach echt? Ich bin die ganze Zeit immer am Sinken und Laden, deswegen weiß ich gar nicht, was meine Abtime ist, aber drei Tage?
Und zwanzig Stunden und der ist circa bei der Hälfte oder knapp drunter in der Batterie. Also sechs Tage ist zu schaffen.
Nein. Doch.
Bist du im Airport-Modus?
Also ich nutze immer WLAN.
Aber du hast Telefon schon eingeschaltet.
Ja, ist alles an.
Ist auch immer an.
Ja, immer. Ist immer alles an. Also Bluetooth nicht, aber WLAN. Ich höre abends vor dem Schlafengehen meistens noch eine Stunde Musik. Dabei ist das natürlich Displays aus, weil ich höre die nur. Und ich SMS eine ganze Menge. Telefonieren eher so ein bisschen weniger. Aber es kommt noch dazu, ich habe zu Hause eigentlich relativ schlechten Empfang. Das heißt, mein Telefon müsste eigentlich so mit ein bisschen mehr Power senden müssen, weil ich zu Hause nicht so guten Empfang habe. Hast ja bestimmt heute gemerkt, als du mich angerufen hast. Dass du immer mal so ein bisschen aussetzt und so. Ich habe zu Hause scheiß Empfang. O2 ist schuld. Die müssen mal updaten. Und ich will Edge haben. Macht endlich. So, jetzt ist es raus. Ja, aber sonst nutze ich es gerade schon so ein bisschen sparsam, muss ich schon zugehen. Man hat ja mal so Phasen und gerade ist da nicht so viel los. Telefoniermäßig und so.
Ja, ich kann sonst auch nichts weiter empfehlen.
Aber hast du nicht gerade irgendwas gesagt von wegen wir wollten doch mal langsam den Ausgang dieser Sendung finden?
Ja, wollten wir.
Zu der wir so blind die ganze Zeit hin tappen.
Dann machen wir das jetzt und sagen Tschüss.
Frohe Weihnachten.
Das war's. Ho Ho Ho, genau, rutscht gut durch, kommt auf den Kongress.
Und wir sehen uns wieder 2009.
Falls wir nicht doch noch am 31. eine Sendung machen. Aber sind wir auf dem Kongress ansprechbar?
Naja, nicht ansprechbar als solche.
Wir sitzen jetzt nicht irgendwo rum und haben einen Mobile-Macs-Tisch.
Ach, eine Stunde hab ich doch komplett vergessen. Ich hab Leo getroffen von... Jetzt weißt du wieder nicht, was das FSC-Klog ist?
Doch, doch, ich lese das jetzt auch immer. Dann ist die News ein bisschen kondensiert, aber so richtig spannend ist es auch nicht. Wo hab ich denn mein Ding dazu? Ich lese das alles schon in Englisch immer. Ich bin halt Mac-Surfer-Leser.
Ja, ich weiß.
Und Mac-Surfer kannst du einfach nicht mehr toppen. Das ist irgendwie die Meta-Meter-Suchmaschine.
Naja, aber den hab ich kennengelernt bei diesem Google-Treffen.
Ach, der war da.
Der war da. Sehr netter Mensch.
Warum hast du mich eigentlich nicht angerufen und eingeladen dahin, mitzukommen?
Weil das so auf der allerletzten Sekunde war, dass ich selber noch unsicher war, ob ich überhaupt reinkomme. Und ich hab da sowieso selber erst, ich hab erst einen Tag vorher davon erfahren, nochmal kurz nachgefragt, dann kam das alles relativ knapp.
Alles ausreden, alles ausreden.
Warst du nicht bei der Logic-Dings-Einführung von Apfel? Du kannst ja nochmal drei Minuten erzählen und dann ist Feierabend. Dann ist aber wirklich Feierabend.
Ich war ja auf einer Apple-Veranstaltung. Ja, das war gestern. Wo denn? Im Sound & Drum Land, das ist da in Kulturbrauerei, dieser große Musikladen. So ein Riesenladen, Sound & Drum Land, da sind dann tatsächlich mehrere Firmen unter demselben Label quasi, die sich halt die Instrumente verkaufen, Studio verkaufen, PA verkaufen machen und so weiter. Ja, und die hatten vor ein paar Wochen angekündigt, dass halt Apple da einen Workshop, wie sie es nannten, machen, über Logic. Und da ich mich ja für Audio-Software so ein bisschen interessiere, auch wenn ich keine Musik damit mache, von daher einen ganz anderen Ansatz habe, hab ich mir das mal angeschaut. Und wie Apple das immer so macht, sie holen sich... Also einer war, es waren zwei Leute da, einer war tatsächlich Apple-Mitarbeiter und der andere war sozusagen angeworben. Genau, ein Anwender, aber schon so einer, der sich das echt gut angeschaut hat, der so jeden Kniff konnte und sich auch die dicken Bücher durchliest und so auch den gezieltesten Fragen beantworten konnte und der vor allem das auch sehr gut gemacht hat. Also das war eine echt hervorragende Gesprächsführung. Ich war echt beeindruckt, wie gut der die Leute adressiert hat, wie gut der auch so reagiert hat, weil es Klagen gab mit irgendwie, kann das nicht sehen, und lass das nochmal erklären und so. Top. War durchaus informativ. Es war natürlich im Wesentlichen so Musikerkram. Ich bin dann auch nochmal aufgestanden, hab so von meinem Podcaster Problemen erzählt und dann kam halt wieder das, was immer kommt. Alle kratzen sich am Kopf.
War das ja nicht gedacht.
Geht das ja nicht.
Das ist für Musik, Mann.
Wieso willst du denn sechs Spuren gleichzeitig aufnehmen in einer Live-Situation? Weil sie haben halt dieses, bei Logic Studio gibt es ja so ein Tool, das heißt Mainstage. Also, weiß nicht, ob du das mitbekommen hast, aber sie haben ja jetzt diese ganze Logic-Sparte, die sie ja mal eingekauft hatten. Dann haben sie so ein, zwei Releases gemacht von der Software, damit wurde das immer immer Mac-iger, immer Apple-iger, weil ja du weißt ja, wie das ist so mit Audio-Software, die ist immer sehr, steht ja immer sehr Betriebssystemfern, damit sie eben, weil sie ja auch Cross-Plattform liefen, das haben sie ja bei Logic dann gleich sein lassen und haben das jetzt in so richtigen... Das gibt es nur noch von Mac und sie setzen halt auch Granaten hart da drauf, Macintosh-Technologien zu leverageen, wie man so schön sagen würde. Und das hat sich bei Logic extrem ausgezahlt und die letzte Version, Logic 8, was jetzt eben auch analog zum Verkaufskonzept von Final Cut auch Studio heißt und sozusagen mehrere Programme bundelt. Also du kaufst jetzt nicht mehr Logic, sondern du kaufst Logic Studio und zu Logic Studio gehört halt Logic oder Logic Pro, also die eigentliche Composer Software, ein unfassbar mächtiges Tool, was mir auch sehr gefällt, aber wo halt immer noch so ein oder zwei Features mir fehlen, damit ich es wirklich nutzbar einbringen könnte. Und dann eben noch so Sachen wie Soundtrack Pro, was vorher auch bei Final Cut dabei ist, aber nicht so richtig reinpassen, damit auch nicht so richtig ordentlich Daten austauschen kann. Und dann gibt es auch noch dieses Mainstage, da hab ich schon glühende Augen bekommen, weil das ist so Custom Interface, wo du wirklich so dein Studio-Equipment oder deine Musikinstrumente, so wie du sie benutzt, vor allem dein Keyboard und so auf dem Bildschirm drängen kannst und dann baust du dir da so große, gut sichtbare Regler und dann belegst du das mit den entsprechenden MIDI-Sachen und so weiter, also assignst das zu dem, was du da tatsächlich wirklich hast. Tolles Interface. Und ich dachte schon so, oh geil, mein Live-Podcast-Interface. Und dann hab ich halt gefragt, kann man damit auch aufnehmen? Und dann haben sie mich halt angeschaut so, warum in aller Welt solltest du in einer Live-Situation aufnehmen wollen? Ah, interessanter Aspekt. Hatten sie halt so noch nie. Klar, gibt's halt auch. Also niemanden.
Und die war auch kostenlos, die Veranstaltung?
Ja, das war kostenlos. Aber es gab zu trinken, es gab glaub ich sogar ein paar Schnittchen.
War auch ohne Anmeldung.
Doch, man sollte sich anmelden, dann haben sie auch schon gemerkt, dass das Interesse groß war. Es war ein riesen Andrang, da waren so 50, 60 Leute. Da haben sie es extra noch, vorher dachten sie, sie könnten es in so ein kleinen Eckchen machen, dann haben sie es extra nach oben in den großen Raum umgezogen und da war es auch ganz schön voll. Also es war ein irres Interesse. Und er hat so ein bisschen rumgefragt, wer schon so ein Long-Term Logic-User ist. Das waren so die wenigsten. Also da waren wirklich eine Menge Leute dabei, die sich ganz neu...
Ist aber bei Apple auch ein bisschen so, kam mir auch schon bei diesem Tech-Talk so vor, dass da auch viele Leute hinkommen, die so Fans sind und sich das einfach nochmal reinziehen wollen.
Oder?
Ja, gibt es sicherlich auch. Aber ich würde sagen, der Großteil war jetzt in dem Fall wirklich Leute, die... Also es waren einerseits Leute da, die eben überhaupt erst mal sich das mal erklären wollten, die von anderen Plattformen kamen. Und dann gab es aber auch so ein paar Hardcore-User, die so Lösungen für ihre paar Probleme suchen wollten. Und das hat der Vortragender ganz gut hingejuggelt. So dass er sowohl die einen als auch die anderen abgelehnt hat. Also da hat Apple einen guten Vortragenden gefunden. Wenn das jetzt einer von Apple hört. Das war wirklich eine der besten Präsentationen. Also auch der Apple-Mitarbeiter, die waren beide wirklich klasse und sehr professionell. Eine der besten Werkstufe veranstalten, die ich so seit langem mitbekommen habe. Na gut, jetzt haben wir aber genug gelobt und so, oder?
Ja, letzte Woche war ja noch der Cocoa-Hats.
Ah, wir haben noch ein Thema.
Nee, ich war nicht da.
Du warst nicht da, verdammt, ich auch nicht. Warum eigentlich nicht?
Ich war schick essen.
Ihr habt beide verpasst sozusagen. Das ist ja doof. Na gut.
Ja, die haben da, also, ich weiß jetzt nicht, wann der nächste ist, weil ich war ja nicht da, aber es werden die wahrscheinlich irgendwie ankündigen und ich glaube, beim nächsten Mal schaffe ich es dann auch wieder. Ich hab da, terminlich bin ich ein bisschen in die Bedrohliche gekommen und man muss ja Prioritäten setzen.
Okay, wir berichten, aber das war's. Wir müssen jetzt Schluss machen hier, der Chat fordert uns auch schon an.
Die schlafen schon alle ein.
Schlafen schon alle ein.
So, ausende.
Tschüss sagen, bis bald.
Schöne Weihnachten, guten Rott, blabla.